hello everybody that's right
it's August 2nd we're here to stay true
podcast
moving through the summer boy I'm
telling you
I got a haircut did it nobody notice
nobody said anything
no comment
looks good I mean I said I said regular
you know the whole ritual about the the
haircut thing
but it's just you know when you get the
standard haircut you don't you don't
expect yeah yeah it is the regular
speculum it's the regular I will say
okay
I'll hold that thought dad
[Music]
I don't know
a little demonic opening for uh our
Christian fans apologies to for the
Spooks to all of our Christian fans
there getting a little demonic there for
a minute it is Wednesday that guitar was
was sick Zach thank you appreciate it it
felt very like
spooky but dub I I would I like to do a
theme every week and the theme was the
uh the Death Bell so I'm like let's make
it some like uh you know some Slayers
hell yeah I like that oh yeah well done
and Well Done Ian of course
on the visuals
visual art
uh yeah so I got a haircut
um I'm very happy I was saying with the
length that she did
um usually it's either two it's usually
too short but I think she nailed it so
God bless to her you know you could
really see my hairline
[Music]
and all of its Glory
and that's important uh today's episode
is sponsored by gamer subs and
stamps.com who we love love thank you
thank you thank you
and thank you to our members
who make the Sun
rise and fall on the H3 podcast Empire
thank you guys so much you know members
get a live episode every Tuesday uh crew
reaction Allure videos we well that's
maybe maybe that one's debatable yeah
access to Discord is not debatable
get to participate in chat impulse and
you get early access to Live show
tickets the new one's about to go up
soon I think
uh that's what it is
as you can tell from the title the uh
Demi Lovato crime family has taken to
Twitter
she responded to our our show on Monday
the sister
and we had a little bit of a back and
forth on Twitter I have to say
the lovados
[Music]
they're gonna regret this one
I'm about to
I'm about to treat their ass like a can
of sugar-free yogurt yo
eat it up easy I'm gonna eat that ass up
easy wow
because there's no sugar in it
your ass
or I have diabetes both are good options
but um we'll talk about that and also we
have a huge huge also lizzo lawsuit I
want to touch on that a little bit it's
pretty interesting and then our main
segment today
prepared by Lena
uh with support from AV is our first
ever H3 True Crime
PowerPoint you're finally getting your
wish
right making your dreams come true you
know I'm a true crime boy and uh well
we've got our first
we've got our first uh PowerPoint and it
it's quick it's only 120 slides we'll
Breeze right through that Prime starting
out small yeah sensible yeah
uh but at the top of the show we've got
Dan
has been has been used commercially damn
well we're talking about this huh
yeah it's at the top oh what but my
angle
hmm
um
check this out Crowder put up a ad
for his mug club and slash Rumble and
he's using footage from our podcast for
commercial use this could be a problem
Crowder
you know what I mean I mean
who the [__] do you think you are
this isn't fair use [__] this is a
commercial use
and if there's a if there's a path for
legal action I'm taking it
right along with all the other suckers
that use my voice for commercial use
check this [__] out
Crowder you [__] hey [__] ass let me
show you what actual fairies looks like
there's this as I watch your video
Stephen what is that Steven Crowder
despicable guy okay you must have opened
it and Discord why is it playing from
Discord the hell okay never seen that
before
here we go
Dad how do you feel about being used in
this way I just thought it was funny I
mean I'm um you're not outraged he's
using her face to make I think it's
funny I've been Crowder the clip is
hilarious I I'm glad that he saw that
yeah stand by what I said let's watch
[Music]
there's this right wing by the way
nobody cares about this [__] anymore
this video has like a hundred thousand
likes after a day he's done being silent
we're coming out of the gate swinging
nobody [__] cares wife abusing
[__] dick showing loser
weirdo ass drug addict too not that
there's anything wrong with drug addicts
but I'm pretty sure he's in favor of
like killing them all
loser kind of way like you are
everything you hate don't you understand
that the only thing he's swinging is his
dick in the office
literally on to his employees that's
right
we're hard named Stephen Crowder Stephen
Crowder despicable God Sam
right only when he didn't show Ah that's
funny that is that was intentional that
was absolutely a little bit interesting
although you get one scared
I mean yeah this may be better yeah it's
even crowded you can't look in The
Velveteen Rabbit that's what I was gonna
say it's too scary you want to jump
scare the audience pickable guy it's
even Crowder who shall be referred to as
Stephen kawada Stephen cower or or
coward
keep damn dude Stephen's wife cowers
from his abusive language yeah
watch it
Stephen
okay extremely massage I won't go on and
on he's also homophobic he's a
disgusting garbage human being he's been
his brand from the very beginning just
go look at the titles of that guy's
videos
horrible offensive there's something and
you're famous
oh
dance we're in love I know him he's the
king what can I say I know him he's the
king of making of saying horrible
offensive stuff yeah and we're not even
talking about like racism we're talking
about like just when you talk to your
wife yeah
you're the king of that [__]
and your employees incidentally too
didn't your co-host like straight up
expose you like one day after you fight
her him as being a freak you have a push
to you have a stop talking button onto
your desk I mean I mean come on dude who
would have that
damn
who who around here would have something
like that
oh sorry
type that videos like he's like the king
of like saying horrible offenses there's
something that's pretty badass that you
got a nod in this though I just noticed
that they were they were bleeping the
swear words he always does this yeah
racism is very friendly uh you know
minor minor
curse words that's gonna cause US
problems like he's like the king of like
saying horrible offenses there's
something
there it is so I'm I'm considering legal
action he's gonna go I am globalistic
here's the letter good let him go
ballistic you you don't have a right to
use my [__] for commercial if you want
to make a haha cute video like look at
these morons that's fine
no but Crowder
you homophobic and also get um
yeah no he's definitely gay okay
come on people at this point
well he said he had to buy yeah that's
it we know from him that he's at a
minimum buy and he
yeah we don't have to go over all the
others okay so he's homophobic and also
gay
he's a drug addict who hates drug uh
drug addicts right he is a a racist
freak
a miserable self-hating loser
um a self-sabotaging loser who had 50
million dollars on the table who
might be a chaser a transpho who can't
stop dressing in drag frankly yeah who
have long-standing rumors about being a
champion so no I will not allow him to
use my footage I'm I'm checking I'm not
even kidding I'm checked with my lawyer
to see if there's any basis because it's
you know what I mean [__] that how did
you become gay I feel like you know when
When Donald Trump uses like born in USA
or something right
then they send him a season assist
that's me
true and uh
you know because I had a red hair
red hair
um I I don't think anyone's gonna look
at me sideways for that frankly because
it's commercial now you gotta ask me
permission [__] yeah I want to cut to
The Mug club I'm taking the mug Club
that's what I'm taking the Mud Club in
the words of keemstar you know I like it
dude
so you do what you want but I I get I
get like a commission that payout right
I'm not getting it there's not gonna be
a payout it's just I think what I wanted
to do is just have to erase it that
would be funny maybe issue an apology
that's good enough for me yeah I'm not
I'm not circling uh seeking monetary
damages even them just having to take it
down would be really fun that's it yeah
just to [__] with him because he's a
piece of [__] yeah why not why not
commercial you're a piece of [__] thank
you foosi you got my back uh so here's
this is just a video I saw that I think
is fantastic that everybody should see
um you know we we give the police a lot
of trouble out here on the show we say I
mean we do say a cab and [__] the police
and all that but
here's an officer a public servant who
is testing the safety of these public
slides for the betterment of of his
community and I applaud him for that
thank you
and um you know I don't think it's safe
no he did something you think he [__]
up how did it that fast how did he end
up
by the time he comes out of the hole no
he must have like
oh [__] me dude
oh
oh [__] that is the best thing ever he
stands up opens fire on them
that's right dump some mag on it
laughs
we need backup
Officer Down
he looked dead but he came out of that
there are other forces that play I don't
know I think I don't know I mean some
slides are not meant for adults it's too
heavy uh maybe it was slicked what are
you what are you in I I think that the
pig had too much bacon grease on him oh
this is a Boston police
Boston you said yes sir yeah
too greasy there huh Bud oh my God next
time you go home you have to take a
video on the slide that's true Kim I
will go down that slide and I want to
see yeah I want to see what really
happens I try to go down the giant slide
in Detroit but they close it down if
they have someone oh the one that we
watched where people were just flying
off of it all the time somebody sued
them yeah yeah what a shock I'm
surprised that didn't happen sooner
probably yeah
shame I would have loved to see you on
that I'm sure you were now on the giant
slide wasn't there a song Let me listen
to a Giants yeah yeah the giant slide
yeah the Giants you could break your
neck on the Giants that's right well
here Boston has its own very own giant
slide
dude he doesn't know where he is he
doesn't know what happened dude almost
grinded the side of that thing oh God
that's funny
I mean based on the way he flies out I
assume I think he hit his head
he definitely bonked his head a few
times what the [__] he was sliding down
like this which is so crazy
it seems like he's up there for too long
like where no he's like flipping or
something I don't I don't know what his
plan was he slammed this wall he slammed
this wall okay that's that's what you're
hearing yeah
lunch
boom
here he comes
so fast we gotta can we fly you out
there for an investigative report cam I
would love it for fans in Boston maybe
can do a no give him the give him a free
flight to Boston yeah give me a free
flight maybe maybe before you know to
make up for never feeding him right
he's so damn hungry so I am actually
pretty hungry oh love you hungry too
yeah
I'm glad to do that food let's get some
food
all right go ahead I'm gonna fight a box
and get some food Boston Market but uh
there's fans in uh Boston
uh who want to take a video of this I'd
love to see it that would be great it's
at uh Boston City Hall there it is thank
you uh cam
the boss tonight
that's right one more time
dude he slid like 20 feet too incredible
there it is
yes sir
hmm
all right now let's move it on to uh one
of our main stories here of course
the Lovato crime family
[Music]
these lovados have had a Stranglehold
on big yogurt for too long
okay
next time you walk into a yogurt store
and you don't see any sugar-free options
remember who's sent man
the Lovato family sends their regards
no sugar-free options kavesh
if I walk into this yogurt store and see
a sugar-free option
it's gonna be a problem
you might say
the yogurt's gonna melt when I set it on
fire
and you better hope you're not in it you
understand the yogurt's gonna melt when
I set it on fire
[Music]
How You Gonna how you gonna make ice
cream are you gonna make yogurt when
your building's on fire kavish
the whole ocean now please I'll take a
I'll take a yogurt with Gummy Bears
I'm sick
[Music]
sick of them
thinking they own the world here's the
original tweet that started this whole
thing by Madison De La Garza
um Demi's sister
she said I've been seeing a lot of
support for Ethan Klein and Trisha
Paytas recently let's not forget the
things that they have both done to
undermine multiple communities and I
will never forget what they said about
my sister they are both horrible human
beings [__] them now girl you knew when
you spoke my name out like this this was
this was going to be a problem
you know what I mean but actually she
clarified for us what is it I did we
went through a full list on Monday what
did I do that that they're holding this
Grudge well
here it is
now once again let me remind you what
she said before I show you this
Ethan Klein has undermined multiple
communities and she will never forget
what I said about her sister I'm a
horrible human being and [__] me here's
what I said
she said clearly Ethan's pretending like
he doesn't even remember the statement
he made in one of his podcasts so in
case you forgot he does not need to
pretend you called my sister a dumb [__]
no oh no you have his pillow that's
unhealthy and be skinny but the sugar
sugar free cookies you dumb [__] yeah I
think I think that was bad because so
there it is that's that's it and I was
like girl that's not even close to the
worst thing I said about her
um and um well my only thought was oh
okay I understand why
seeing sugar-free yogurt ruined your
whole week because now it's someone
saying dumb [__] ruined your whole 2.5
years and then I had a hard time the
rest of the week like how how soft are
you dummy
soft as that yogurt softest frozen
yogurt that's right so I tweeted a few
responses uh she responded to me too
it's quite good quite good
so she was here's what I said
when sugar-free yogurt can ruin your
week I understand why this would be
causing problems for your family 2.5
years later
Fair she said I respect anyone's opinion
on the situation
not really
what's what's this like the yogurts yeah
the yogurt situation dude what what
are you still talking about this weren't
you all embarrassed
it wasn't even her
your sister well the way she's talking
she's really representing Demi like in a
sense I feel that I'm speaking with Demi
because why is she so invested in she
both sisters right this is a
conversation with me and demi glaze
[__]
and Demi what demi-glaze
[Laughter]
because I'm about to Demi okay I'm not
gonna say that
I'll I'll find a good use for demi glaze
then it's like a sauce right yeah it's
just a demi-glaze
it's a rich brown sauce in French
cuisine it demi glace demi-glace
okay yeah and I learned that's the new
word of the day for me
that's a deep cut you've never heard of
demi glaze no I don't know the [__] dude
really is this like common knowledge a
rich brown sauce in French cuisine I I
don't know I mean I I I you watch more
cooking shows than me I guess it's from
the uh ligma family oh is it oh really
no
it's like a pot roast sauce I mean damn
I thought you worked in restaurants you
never heard you never demi-glazed you're
working in a steakhouse and I also don't
eat meat so this might explain why I'm
not familiar
that's fair I'm the meat chef
well I'm about to Demi I'm gonna treat
her ass like a fine pot roast and demi
glaze the [__] out of her
from the secondi islands
it's from the what now the secondi
islands oh right the white candy islands
is that is that the island Napoleon swim
back from yeah the second Island
is that where the demi glaze was
invented the second is nuts [__] yeah
what's your problem
where are you coming from
yo dude what did I do to you you coming
out with a suck on these nuts
[Music]
about the demi-glaze your ass if you
don't wipe down
um
anyway she said I respect anyone's
opinion on the situation just not sure
why such harsh and hateful words were
necessary
okay by the way this was not and has
never been about sugar-free yogurt it's
bigger
this is bigger than the yogurt this is
about
other things
like Diet culture yeah
I think
honestly my read on the situation and
like I could be totally wrong is I
wonder if she watched the show and
obviously like for for demi this
situation with the frozen yogurt stemmed
from like other things Demi's talked
about
um her eating disorder and how that's
like prominent in their family I think
so I wonder if she was watching you guys
just like talk about her sister in like
such a
insensitive but like you guys just talk
like that but it is her sister and she
was there for that so I wonder if it
like struck a nerve and she was like
these are people I watch they're talking
about my sister definitely I mean
clearly she was clearly right but like
let's revisit her original statement
here Isis
um she said
oh by the way she said for anyone who's
worried about how thick my skin is this
has been my whole life I'm fine let the
cards fall where they may not my
problems right it's your sister's
problem it's got to deal with the yogurt
allegations again
now is she like in the public eye this
she is actually she's she's as
she did acting growing up
um let me see what she's up to today
I've been seeing a lot of remember this
is what she said I've been seeing lots
of support for Ethan Klein and Trisha
Paytas recently let's not forget the
horrible thing or the undermining
multiple communities what the [__] did I
do undermine the yogurt well she hasn't
she hasn't uh doesn't clarified that one
but the second half of the statement I
guess is the uh the dumb [__] uh okay
and I will never forget what they said
about my sister dumb [__] foreign
sorry it looks like uh Madison is
directing screenwriting and producing
right now
right so nothing she's probably working
on a horror film attack of the diet for
yogurt what'd you say Dan I said so
unemployed
yeah that's what I mean I got it and not
just and especially correct especially
because of the stroke yeah yeah she was
unemployed before the story that's true
talentless probably why
Jesus we don't know that I don't we
don't know that her sister is extremely
talented I could tell her that she's a
beautiful singer but yeah it's like this
do you ever make a movie oh right um no
common I don't know Camp Rock
but I'll say this I could tell her
temperament is a little [__] off
I mean because I if she's a director
that's gonna there's this is not gonna
be a good situation imagine one of the
Pas walks in with with sugar-free yogurt
will ruin the whole [__] week it's
gonna be like that Tom Cruise incident
where he just yelled at everyone yeah oh
that wasn't Tom Cruise it was Christian
Bale Christian Bale yeah no Tom Cruise
did it as well he had a diva moment yeah
oh yeah wait when I was during covet
someone wasn't wearing a mask I thought
that was Vibes I like that oh no no it
was it was yeah that was dub yeah the
Christian Bale one was a little wild
yeah I think the like intense emotional
response is pretty indicative that she
was a fan for sure do you think she's a
fan I think that she was and then like
it was hurtful when she heard that's
what Olivia was trying to say is that
she was watching it oh as a fan and then
suddenly her sister's catching Strays
and like
I am her biggest fan I see okay but
still it was two and a half years ago
what the [__] yeah move on Madison
and the other sister quote tweeted it
too but there was another response
that I leveled against her uh what
brought this up you think because she
said I guess I don't know I said Trisha
and Ethan have been getting a lot of
positive and support on the internet
right now Trisha was getting some
support thing but but I didn't feel like
everybody hates you you know the same
that they always do yeah people have
always hated me sorry Madison nice try I
have an alternate idea go ahead I wonder
if she came
for you both
if she wants Frenemies back
she's playing 40 chess maybe yeah I
don't know I don't think the Lovato's
operate on that high level they live
their lives they're more of a chest
they're more of a Checkers people yeah I
saw someone point out that uh Trisha and
uh the sister had been on the same
podcast
and I feel like that could have
triggered it somehow I think it's the
Colleen stuff uh by also the um
dude what was that I saw this it looked
like Trisha was in like blackface on
this podcast no no no no no she was on
uh Chrissy Carlson Romano's podcast Kim
Possible and she didn't look like super
dark like the cartoon lip drawn on she
looked like Samuel Jackson no
those are her words her words for
anybody that doesn't know the background
she she thinks she looks like anyway I
responded to her uh tweet about I
respect anyone's opinion and I said
I think it's nice that you that all you
siblings have your sisters back even if
she was being a dumb [__] at the time
family
and of course you know the irony being
that I called her a dumb [__] again
right right that shows how little I care
yeah
then what now
what now
Madison De L Garza
that's right can I find that Samuel
Jackson on that one podcast yeah I need
uh
yeah what the [__] dude what is this no
offense but what the [__] is this it's
Kim Possible dude do you want me to send
you a photo of Kim Possible
is she what color is Kim Possible skin
uh well she's cartoon character but
she's she's a white character but her
upper lip is
like a black
all right let me see Kim Possible you
don't know Kim Possible
you don't know what Demi's
hi dude
all right let me see Kim Possible
I mean it's this character why is the
why is her skin dark why did you say
that it's just this you see how you sent
the hot as soon as I sent it I'm like
wait is that her usual outfit
impossible he sent a cleavage like sexy
version
a little more racy that's not on Google
when you search
little folders on it is you look at them
there it is there's my search I was just
trying to find a close-up
tits pitch okay so do you agree there's
her skin tone got a little haywire here
uh am I the only one it might be the
shadowing that you're talking about but
no I don't think so well I mean I mean
because she has red hair she should have
fair skin
like she should be more white not more I
mean I guess but she's probably trying
to do some like cartoon shading it could
be the lighting too I don't know I can't
tell from the screenshot
okay here cam can you get us one of the
lighting where she's in blackface where
the with the true lighting
let's move on
there it is shout out to uh
well Dave we're on the same level
we both are ruining communities left and
right
um Madison let's see
Madison and her mom are a tick tock live
this was pretty great
let's take a look
come on it was one of them twos that
called into our show by the way
and the mom we don't know that for sure
good I know we had the whole discussion
about it yes yesterday on Monday yeah
Maybe
now
here you can see the mom doesn't know
who we are someone asked about hey do
you want to go on HD podcast because I
said I want to interview them
okay so now we're gonna eat
even for the first gifts you guys that
means for your podcast okay please tell
me what's going on you [__] up reading
that out loud girl
okay so it was for sure the sister the
mom doesn't even know
well how does she know it's a man she
said I don't even know that man
is that what she said hold on the name
is Jonathan okay so now we're gonna Eva
thank you
yep thank you for the first gifts you
guys why is Demi Lovato's family on here
begging for [__] Tick Tock stickers
I mean what the [__] have some damn
dignity
thank you for the five cents for the
family for the family name
you know is Demi not hooking you guys up
from the prime
she's not she's not sharing the wealth
Demi Lovato net worth she's a pretty big
deal right
40 million
she's from Albuquerque
what's your problem with Albuquerque
what do you know about
nothing
well Gators I know there's Gators there
no that's in Arizona bro
I know there's Gators in Albuquerque
from Arizona
in New Mexico Maybe yeah it's in New
Mexico
my name is so foul
what did I do I feel that we could bury
the hatchet
we could bury the yogurt if it were
because there's really
me and you we haven't wronged each other
so much have we
I know you called into the show
wouldn't it be nice to be able to watch
I don't know that
I need to keep well according correct 89
of our audience it was her in the
opinion of a lot a large majority of the
audience one of them may have called
into the show anonymously wouldn't it be
nice to be able to watch uncomfortable
the show again and just be a part of the
community without feeling that
animus
you know for the yogurt incident from
two and a half years ago I want you
to come back to the family well you need
to bridge a gap you need to apologize
for calling her sister a dumb [__] I do
apologize yeah
but they did they have to accept some
accountability that this was very silly
I don't think they're willing to accept
the silliness of what that was
of the yogurt incident or of bringing it
back up of the yogurts they seem to not
want to accept any blame for that
you know well Demi apologized for that
did she was fake obviously Hollow this
is her sister it's not dead both sisters
it was obviously Hollow you don't think
they don't talk
he obviously goes and begs her for money
at least once a month keep her ass off
Tick Tock live and then I had a hard
time the rest of the weekend straight up
panhandling
I will
pay you for the appearance
what we never do that we can't I'm
extending that to her because she needs
the money
oh man
I'm extending the Olive Branch or the
the row The Tick Tock Rose emoji that
costs one cents I'll get you a bunch of
those
in a dozen
I'll buy you thousands of those girl
bury you in them
[Music]
and this is you know just the
and actually you know what I'm willing
to even start a show with your sister
called smart [__]
and here we can bury the hatchet
together
Dude any suit
[Music]
together at last
so it's a heartwarming tale of
redemption and
friendship unlikely places
take the yogurt leave the sugar free
why does this look like James Charles
oh my god that's literally James Charles
a little bit
whose face is that is that Demi yeah why
is it James Charles though so
embarrassing just the makeup
oh
so
um
you know what more can I say I
I do apologize let me let me I do
apologize for calling your sister a dumb
[__]
I did say worse things I apologize for
those two
that language was not appropriate it was
it wasn't appropriate you could be
critical of somebody without calling
them a dumb [__] and that's where I
[__] up
um
you know
so I do apologize
um
Madison
and uh if you want I'll even get you
like one of those bronchiosaurus
stickers on Tick Tock what did those run
for
almost at least a dollar at least a buck
a whole dollar yeah I'll get you a
Brachiosaurus tick sticker if you come
on
later okay am I wrong though this is
weird that they're like
they're they're on here to make like two
bucks there's 86 people watching okay so
now we're gonna Eva thank you
yep thank you for the first gifts you
guys thank you for your podcast unless
they're being paid for whatever they're
doing
by who for 85 views
that's a good point
see what's going on I can't I just
started out she's starting out her Tick
Tock career you gotta start somewhere
right well I'll tell you something
support small creators some people might
say oh well um they just started the
stream that's why the views aren't up
well watch it starts at 86 and goes down
to 80s so now we're gonna even look at
that they're losing fluctuation a little
fluctuating first gift stable 85. okay
please also I think it's important to
note that our fans as well
like we just talked about them so
they're probably in there because of
that too 50 of them are HP podcast
viewers
that leaves 35 people that's like
basically just the sisters and their
friends watching
yeah
it did go up back to 86 at the end so
maybe I'm wrong
Maybe I'm Wrong
all right I'm glad we covered that the
the uh the Lovato crime family
I'm coming for Rico charges I just love
that phrase picked me up every time
y'all been racketeering this game for
too damn long
they should open a yogurt store just no
no sugar free only sugar only sugar [__]
diabetic people
diabetics not welcome
mm-hmm
that's what I'm waiting for
um all right let's do our ad
we'll come back we'll talk about uh this
is ADS there's two ads and we'll talk
about the lizard thing and then we'll
jump right in to the horrific world of
H3 True Crime
and who couldn't be excited for that I
love True Crime I'm looking forward to
this
um
why do these people look so similar
I mean if I could say something nice
about Demi I don't think she's as bad as
James Charles
right
if I had to save one I'd save her right
if you had to save one you'd save her
but because she's
we love her more I don't love her more
but James deserves to I yeah
I know what you're saying to I didn't
say anything to be held accountable
exactly 100
okay Ethan calm down let me let me Focus
because
Ethan is getting a little too goblet
mode already today yeah
living up to the off the rails man get
it get it together come on hold it rain
in it here we go people keep saying Help
Reckless Ben let me talk about Reckless
Ben this guy put up a video about uh
what What's the name of that haunted
house I've watched all about it I know
all about that guy mccamey Manor
okay yeah
this guy is an actual absolute freak and
he should probably be in jail so this
guy made a video about it and he put out
a video he says Ethan please contact me
let's get in touch so I can help you and
I said okay cool I'm gonna contact this
guy go on Twitter
does he or I don't know if he had his I
don't think he has a Twitter so I went
on Instagram he doesn't follow me on
Instagram I have no way to contact him
I literally went to each option for him
and there's I have no way to contact him
you know what I mean
I'm out of the loop on this so why does
he need your help he's just his video
got taken down for um graphic or being
too graphic God I got it but I guess the
original videos stayed up and he's
saying you know what's the deal
and I actually I was gonna send the URL
to my YouTube reps but I need the
original URL
which only you have
so how am I supposed to help you is is
this him help me help you dude
what maybe
found an Instagram account yeah he's on
Instagram he doesn't follow me oh so you
can I see I can't DM him his are open
maybe he just opened them but his are
open it says oh open so what I mean but
that's not right how's he even gonna see
it he doesn't you know what I mean yeah
I mean I can message him hey you here
it's literally just goes into The Ether
of every [__] person
he'll probably see it now yeah and talk
about it I just thought that was funny
I've never been asked for help and then
had no way to get in touch with them
yeah I'll send it to um my YouTube Red I
just need the URL
versus email too kabish
and that's uh
all I can say about that okay Reckless
Ben checked off shot him a little
reckless if you ask me
okay
not bad thanks for coming out all right
listen let's thank our sponsors
um gamer sup oh
[Applause]
we love gamer sup we love gamer Souls
new flavors coming out at the end of the
month
[Music]
it's time to get canceled
should I not do that
that was I'm not supposed to do that
right yeah or do I always do that you're
not supposed to yeah okay where were we
by the way I was watching the show where
we did the four buttons it was so funny
it was just such a disaster
and just enough explanation got through
that yeah yeah it actually was coherent
it was way more coherent than I expected
so perfect you're like oh there's this
video we can't show and then it cuts
yeah
the last thing you said is we love gamer
Subs we have a new flavor coming out oh
thank you baby yeah we love gamer Subs
we got a new flavor coming out at the
end of the month it's our flavor yeah
and this is tested by everybody here
formulated to Perfection yeah we had a
whole little focus group uh we went back
and forth with them what like three or
four we sent it back said this isn't
enough not good enough they sent it back
they sent a line I snorted it just
kidding don't do that don't do that not
endorsing do I need to hit the button
again no you're fine
do not snort gamer Subs drink it it's a
drink drink
[Music]
do not do that
but uh the flavor is good you don't even
have taste receptacles in your nose
you'll waste you don't even have to
think about it dude
yeah that's coming out the end of the
month man I'm so excited
uh but until then you know you gotta get
your gamer Subs in I'm talking uh this
is the one I always hit is black cherry
you can't mess with it it's good I know
you all have your own flavors though
that you like blue res all different
flavors
mango meta do we have the Pina Colada
here I really want to try that one yeah
we they send us like everything has
anyone tried the Pina clothes everything
I've tried the pineapple one yeah I've
had different pineapple but yeah pina
colada
you're like pina colada I love pina
we have it
oh [__]
yeah but you know um
we're gonna have our own Cup coming out
too they have a ton of Cups options
they're all have really cool art shakers
so you can shake it up it gets all fully
dissolved
anyway uh gamer Subs is a fantastic
sponsor we love them so please support
them if you're in the market for some
kind of energetic beverage gay you know
gamer they have caffeine three eyes too
caffeine free options hydration drinks
drinks drinks
go to gatormersup dodge
gamersupps.gg and use the code H3 to get
10 off your order nice
go to gamersubs.ugn use code H3 to get
10 off your order thank you so much to
gamer subs for sponsoring us thank you
[Music]
nice song Jack
like that one keep it going for the
other AD sure let's roll on through
groovy
here's another one stamps.com oh yeah
one of the best sponsors I am so loyal
to stamps.com the best please support
them if you're in the market if you're
running a small business
if you are a big business or you just
mail a lot of stuff stamps.com is going
to revolutionize your life
okay stamps.com has gets it because
they've been in business for 25 years
helping over a million
businesses
do the math on that it's a lot of
business it's a lot of business you know
and you can now with stamps.com it's
going to save you so much time so much
money you can focus on your business
instead of shipping which is such a
nightmare dude
um here's what they do for you all you
need is a computer and a printer they'll
send you a free scale which is you know
that's all you need to get started so
you take the package you put it on the
scale you print the postage
done dude done and then you could drop
it off at the post office or you can
even schedule a pickup are you freaking
kidding me like you don't have to do
anything do you put in your mailbox go
to the about Dropbox
it why would you not use this here's it
and if that's not a good enough reason
here's another one
stamps.com has huge discounts up to 84
off USPS and UPS rates whoa
what what was that number again 84
percent
because they do such crazy volume
million they can negotiate massive
discounts from the carriers
right not sure I like it plus stamps.com
automatically tells you your cheapest
and fastest shipping option love it 25
years
stamps.com has been indispensable for
over one million businesses get access
to the USPS and UPS Services you need
right from your computer anytime day or
night no lines no traffic no waiting
so set up your business for Success when
you get started with stamps.com today
sign up with the promo code H3 for a
special offer that includes a four-week
trial plus free postage and a free
digital scale there's no long-term
commitment or contracts just go to
stamps.com Click the microphone at the
top of the page and enter the code H3
thank you so much to stamps.com thank
you to our sponsors
please consider supporting them
if it's uh something you need hey thank
you
all right let's give we don't have pina
colada I guess can we buy it we don't
have pina colada or ask for it
we could buy it yeah if you could buy it
use code H3 though code H3 10 off
all right so we talked about Lovato
crime family
wait no there's more
but there's more
the brother or cousin started following
everybody on Instagram how did you
notice this Olivia was that you
yeah I saw it in my uh notifications
when I woke up and I was just like I
know that last name you think he's
spying or do you think he wants to
connect maybe he wants to connect I
don't know does he want to Parlay a deal
of peace or lay a piece between the
great crime families
between the family the H3 family and the
avado family it could be something
Beauty
so then so he only Falls 880 which isn't
like insane
what was this that's the show that Demi
follows him Demi follows him yeah
and he followed
all of us did he he followed everybody
yeah yeah then if he did that he's look
he wants someone to reach out I think no
I can totally reach out if you want me
to just say hey what's up just say hey
what's up yeah
you might think that I'm trying to flirt
I think it's no if I just say hey what's
up
you want so you want a guy to message
you
but I can be like hi hey girl don't say
hey what's up you could use more attack
than that I don't think about it just
say it's about time the two great crime
families come together at last
if I send a voice note now there is a
peace between us
our coverage of this great state has
increased twice our income is higher
than ever
we've removed all sugar-free options
from every yogurt store in the state
and yet still there's a problem
her name is Demi
she says she's gonna
bring the sugar free
gotta do something about this Demi this
Demi Grace
all right yeah I just sent him a message
it transcribed that I did it it's
already sent
oh yeah here it is he followed Ian
Olivia Sam Ila Lena didn't follow me
yeah he follows literally all of us yeah
he felt yeah and Teddy fresh and the H3
podcast yeah then that just happened
maybe he hates his family
we're gonna get to this is but this is
something it's like there's so many
interesting developments in this story
they making it so juicy for me
all right shout out braid Brayden
let's go my boy braid and my boy
friend of the show Brayden
De La Garza
he's an actor prolific actor as I
understand it
and a very talented musician as well
also very beautiful handsome guy
oh he is
yeah you said the cousin right
brother cousin cousin I'm reading cousin
yeah so he he might be we just knew he
had the last name right he's a cousin
he's got to be a fan if you followed all
of us
because why would he follow the show
he's looking for First Contact
all right I'll give it to him show us
go on
oh God
somebody said Braden are you here right
now that's a good question Braden are
you here right now
like a Ouija board yeah
all right well there it is
all right let's talk about this lizzo
lawsuit
now I thought lizzo was beloved but it
seems like there's a ton of people who
are like I finally get to hate lizzo
publicly
I feel like there are a lot of fat
phobic people who are using this as an
opportunity to be fat phobic
um
but lizzo deserves
all the canceling and without the fat
phobia because it's the least of her
worries you know well apparently she was
according to this fat shaming someone
which is correct answers which is pretty
pretty awesome to be honest in terms of
hype uh you know irony
yeah
um
but I think it's important to remember
that I'm not even gonna say it actually
it's important to remember that because
hold on one sec let me send you a note
Dan
this is never good
what do we got
mm-hmm but that's fair I can say that
right does it undermine me
[Music]
right did that could that be used
against me I don't think so this was not
nearly as uh offensive as I thought it
was going to be
yes so it's it's important to remember
that these are just alleged right these
are just some former employees that are
alleging some pretty wild stuff right
although by all accounts it does seem
like she's a giant b word
oh not like Giant in that sense
nobody thought that but you I heard
Snickers I think it was the b word part
was B word's funny now
no not giant though she's a normal I
mean not normal size but she's a b word
no reference to size no everyone was on
the same page he's a b word lizzo sounds
like a bad person she's a bad baddie bad
um no commentary about her figure
which you know
as a member as a I guess I don't know if
I'm a member or forward member of the
fat Community x x member I'm still obese
technically I checked my BMI no not
obese I I graduated from obese to
overweight oh
yeah congrats thank you
[Applause]
all right so let's read through this Liz
was being sued by three former dancers
for alleged sexual harassment and
creating a hostile work environment
two allegedly were pressured into nude
photo shoots
one woman claimed to be nearly assaulted
by lizzo
clay was filed in La her production
company's big big girl big touring Inc
can I so but like okay
I'm not I mean the type that in the in
her own business it's big girl big
touring yeah so I like I can acknowledge
that she's big yeah that's no secret
it's not there's nothing wrong with it
just that she is big
because when I said giant then you all
said I went too far nobody
that's not what happened
okay
I'm gonna get in trouble today yeah
I'm one simmer down really
tone it down bring it down it's rewind
time
bring it down
all right let's see
um the various allegations by the
defendant they claim sexual and racial
harassment disability discrimination
assault and Felts imprisonment did we
ever find what the hell the false
imprisonment I've been Googling around I
Olivia has a decent Theory yeah that's
referring to I read through all the
complaints I think this qualifies as
false imprisonment
um lizzo allegedly told the dancers they
would have to audition again according
to the suit leading to an excruciating
12-hour rehearsal in which Davis soiled
her own pants because she was too
fearful of losing her job to use the
bathroom
that's crazy I I read this whole thing
too and I have to
I I did chuckle when I read that I'm
sorry I mean because I was like girl
what
but false imprisonment and it implies
that you're being imprisoned well she
was scared that she was going to be
fired if she were to leave so I wonder
if but right that was what I was
thinking too can you and can you falsely
okay I I see what you're saying anything
yeah because they could still they sell
the choice to leave so well that's a
really strong
charge that's like a crime state of
being imprisoned without legal Authority
that's like saying I'm blocking the door
you can't leave but you know I mean
there's been certain cases where I can
recall where people were imprisoned just
by the um
like in cultish Behavior with like Keith
Rainier as he got discharged is it
possible like the more serious
allegations like those details haven't
been released or the entire lawsuit has
been released the initial complaint is
is out right
the complaint yeah yeah I had the
complaint right you read the complaint
then I think that that's I think that
that's it that'd be it
uh but uh what was the part about uh
that's not funny by the way that she
[__] herself apparently
alezo allegedly told dancers they would
have to audition again according to the
suit
hmm
[__] dude uh Grace Just donated 20 and
said the false imprisonment was because
one of the dancers was fired and held by
security okay her phone was confiscated
to have photos that's false imprisonment
yeah that makes sense that's [__] up
yeah I thank you Grace uh okay all the
articles that had write-ups about this
didn't okay really clarify that so yeah
they did tell the story about she tried
to like record a conversation so that
she could have it like later if she was
complaining about obviously her horrible
treatment and then lizzo like okay that
makes a lot of sense that's [__] up
that's definitely
some imprisonment going on there but I
was reading this so uh
they they let
[Music]
uh lizzo allegedly told the dancers they
would have to audition again according
to suit leading to it
what is getting you man
excruciating 12-hour rehearsal in which
Davis
soiled her pants because she was too
fearful of losing her job to use the
bathroom
that's horrible I mean it speaks to the
culture right
but [__] pan I mean so like okay
I'll pretend like it's not funny at all
it does sound like an imprisoned
story you know what I mean
well that wasn't the imprisonment yes
that was just a rehearsal I expect you
guys to take [__] your pants before mids
show Absolutely yeah no problem no
worries no [__] bathroom breaks
during the show you understand I locked
the bathrooms during the show actually
um
it just it just surprised me it just it
took me by by surprise
I never read a complaint where they're
like I [__] myself
and that's why
maybe excelling to think about it a bit
further they might have like uh like a
lot of clothes on or something right
during the performance and it's hard to
take off and it's like actually no there
was there actually a better part of it
of This was
um I need more the second sentence says
they gave her like a tiny little thing
white thing to wear it you could see the
[__] through it oh no and that's I think
that was the [__] up part is they
humiliated her right not that she [__]
her pants right because I mean at the
end of the day
you know we're all Pence [__] at one
point in our life and
um
Zach for example [__] on somebody's lawn
[__] yeah man in their car separate
incidents
I [__] in someone's car I got Rosebud
all over their car
right you you just had an ass that
leaked in a car but it wasn't [__] as
you as you look for that I'll keep
reading uh the complain alleges lizzo
encouraged her crew to touch the nude
performance and engage in other explicit
sexual acts with them lizzo then turned
her attention to Miss Davis and began
pressuring mistavs to touch the breast
of one of the nude women the lawsuit
reads Davis declined but lizzo allegedly
led a chant encouraging him to do it
Davis briefly touched the performer's
breast and was mortified
uh that same night Liz was supposedly
pressured a member of our security team
to get on stage and his pants were
pulled down exposing his buttocks yeah
that's sexual assault
right I mean what the [__] she sounds
wild I think that's the part that like
people didn't expect she is like a
full-on degenerate like
geez about a week later lizzo invited
her dancers out in Paris allegedly
telling them they were going to a place
with live dancing performers and that
they would be able to learn something or
be inspired by that it was a nude
Cabaret Bar
I mean
that seems like it doesn't seem like
that that one I'm just gonna say it's
like okay I mean it's nude cabarets
that's not like pornographic right I
mean it's
these girls with feathers and do like
this right actual dance
doesn't seem
I don't know
touring musicians going and doing wild
stuff after a show well I don't know
she's far from the only one to do that
right
it's not saying the behavior is okay
some of this is [__] up but I just
this one seems like a little bit of a
stretch and I'm sorry okay I know we all
want to hold on just a little technical
issue here we have some technical issue
it sounds like we do about it what are
we gonna do
[Music]
ha ha ha ha ha
really I don't I think people are
I don't even hear
you heard it because it was a reference
to
I just think it's safe yeah yeah yeah I
don't know if I got it though yeah it's
30 seconds it's 20 but yeah I'm
surprised you didn't think so Dan
let's just move on I guess I don't know
it didn't
all right that's the first button sure
[Music]
second yeah that's the second one wait
it is what was the first one during the
ad it's all right right right right
right right right
today what do I do how do I calm down
well thankfully uh Lena will be leading
uh most of the episode after this I've
almost made it through yeah you just
have to get through the rest of the
story and then it's out of your hands
just don't play Chestnut Zack please
figure out
um lizzo allegedly told the dancers that
they would have to audition again oh
this is one we read did you were able to
find that it's in the complaint or the
one where she berated her for her weight
it was right after this sentence no it
was she gave him like maybe it was from
the complaint that's why you can't I
don't know
about the it's just she was given a
see-through outfit with no undergarments
to finish the performance yeah the
lawsuit alleged yeah oh yeah yeah
see-through undergarments
with no undergarments he threw outfit
with no undergarments that's probably
the the part the humiliation part yeah I
mean that seems pretty wild especially
if she had a shitty ass humiliate
somebody
you know it it only says soiled we don't
actually know if it was poopy soiled but
you think she maybe she peed pink is
soil oh that's fair that's true that's
true yeah it's a definition
you know what if you if you pee your own
pants you've soiled yourself that's that
still counts right let me look it up
because that is an interesting point the
only things when a child regularly poos
their pants well this that's the NHS if
they're already potty trained the
soiling I get I think it might mean
specifically pooping pooping pants
um
it can mean other things I'm looking if
it's commonly referenced to uh I mean
this is a legal document though we need
to be precise listen to this to stain or
defile yeah
she defiled her pants where's the best
place to [__] in a Walmart
to control uh to lose control of one's
bowels I think it means [__] okay well
maybe solid is an adjective that
describes something that has become
dirty well I know it's soiled beans yeah
right
oh
you know I think it's vague though it's
slightly vague it's a little vague it
feels like it could be either button to
mislead yeah it could have been pee and
soil yeah and you use soil to make
people jump to that conclusion well
regardless she had to change and they
gave her see-through yeah I mean it's
bad either way you know what I mean yeah
thanks Zach
um so not to defend lizzo but I just
that that one stuck out as me as like
you know
I don't know
uh Davidson Williams alleged that they
were pressure to participate in a nude
photo shoot as contestants on her show
in May 2023 Davis was fired on the spot
after lizzo believes she privately
recorded a meeting
Miss Davis has a habit of making audio
recordings of stressful interactions so
she can review them later in less
stressful environments the lawsuit says
the zoo became Furious hurling
expletives at the group and stated that
she was going to go around the room
person by person until someone told
lizzo who made the recording well that
implies that it was leaked or something
right because yeah
and for sure there's an NDA in place the
complete alleges lizzo and Quigley took
turns berating Davis
before she was fired Davis claimed she
was confined to a room against her will
that you certainly cannot do
he has a security team searched her
phone you can't search your phone either
freak it's crazy
even the police can't do that without
like a warrant nah
you know
but here's where it gets more
interesting a few more people came out
from outside the lawsuit to speak
against lizzo lizzo's former creative
director and one of her former dancers
have both co-signed the lawsuit saying
it reflects their experiences check this
out
creative director that's a pretty high
level job
uh they said I'm not a part of the
lawsuit but this was very much my
experience and my time there I very much
applaud the dancers courage to bring
this into light there it is
wow
echoing what
that person said haven't been a part of
that world for around three years for a
reason I very much applaud the dance
discouraged to bring this to light and I
grieve parts of my own experience I'd
appreciate space to understand my
feelings so she definitely is a tyrant
yeah it's disappointing she seemed nice
she played the crystal flute yeah that
was wholesome
I just took a DNA test turns out I'm 100
that b word
yeah that's a real lyric of hers right
yes now it's become literal I guess
I wonder if she'll play the flute in her
apology video man she you know what
that's true she could deliver us an even
better apologies oh that's a good
suggestion Zach I thought the toxic
gossip train needed a little bit of flu
yeah
Miss Davis was pressed on as long as she
could until she eventually lost control
of her bladder
Still Still fearing the repercussions of
exiting the stage so she pissed herself
bladder I called it see and not that it
makes it better but yeah I do feel that
well it says bladder so they say it okay
so she peed herself seemed like most
people did agree that soiled leans
towards poopy and leans poopy should we
do a poll or do you want to do a poll on
it okay the soiled main pee poop or both
does soiled mean p if you want to watch
a streamer that wants to pee in the
potty
or both then watch anyone but me what
the [__] is that quartering
I think it's poop but um you know how
the conservatives were losing their mind
because she played the crystal flute
they defiled the pure Crystal flute they
were James Madison's Crystal flute our
most precious relic of the United States
they were right she should have never
played that Crystal flute yeah good
people only girl is gonna love this
she's always talking about lizzo who
Pearl
has like a million lizard videos I think
maybe him
well lizzo is is uh to Pearl what Brie
Larson is to the quartering
Tim we're going crazy
thank you Pearl who could might end up
being a stand-in for lizzo if she gets
into enough trouble okay well this is
interesting the majority of people are
saying both 50 second place poop uh 37
so soiled can be pee
very bad pulled the soiled mean pee poop
both how is that bad
that's a perfect pull thank you because
I wrote it oh I guess that's true I
can't take credit
so what was the fat shaming and stuff
because I'm interested in that she was
apparently like
uh that I'm interested in because it's
so ironic right it was in that same uh
NBC article about uh it was specifically
this is I don't think it gave specifics
at least from what I saw it was just she
allegedly would make comments about some
of the dancers weights
oh
that's because of course she's like all
about body positivity and stuff yeah
that's what I think makes it so shocking
and juicy of a story to people is that
that is part of her celebrity identity
body positivity thing so for her to be
doing that is pretty crazy okay here's
the line and I read this in the
complaint and tell me what you think the
suit accuses lizzo of calling attention
to the dancer's weight after an
appearance at South by Southwest Music
Festival the singer and her
choreographer later told the dancer
Ariana Davis that she seemed less
committed to her role a commitment that
suit described as a thinly veiled
concern about Davis's weight
that's the best example they have yeah
that's a little
vague but I don't know
you know in context maybe I haven't seen
maybe she was dropping the ball on the
dance floor yeah
but like she was dropping the ball on
the Dance I mean you know but like I'm
sorry but if you're gonna accuse lizzo
of fat shaming I don't I think you need
better receipts than this literally said
the singer and her choreographer later
told her that she seemed less committed
to her role
a comment that's that the suit describes
as thinly veiled that was heavily veiled
because I don't I don't know why less
committed necessarily means you need to
lose weight
and I mean what I mean lizzo's like
she's a really good performer and dancer
and she's obviously has a larger figure
yeah so
yeah I agree I wouldn't need that to be
explicitly stated or at least I don't
know
you know what I mean it's just that I
don't know
I know you all want me to [__] [__]
on lizzo right now
but
I'm just calling it like I see it
I'm not saying she's wrong or that
everything's wrong and that claim and
that's the um that's the huge
um claim that's going out that's the
headline lizzo fat shame dancer I have
the whole story from the paperwork if
you want to hear it
or just wanted sent
wait what
like directly from the law school you
want to hear it sure this quote is from
the lawsuit I think I read through the
complaint right now there's only four
mentions of weight and it's all vague
there's no specific instance it talks
about how in general a weight gain means
this it's considered that a dancer may
be lazy and then uh the person who made
the complaint said that lizzo had
previously called attention to her after
noticing uh her weight gain during a
South by Southwest Music Festival uh and
then by saying she's less committed
right right again it's very vague
there's no I don't know if that one's
gonna hold up in a court you know well
the thing is that inference like that
this is I feel like really damaging to
lizzo because of her body positivity and
this is the headline that everyone's
running with right I mean
I think it's
I'm not seeing it I'm just not seeing it
less committed Dan I'm feeling you're
less committed today you're looking a
little less committed than you were last
week you know what I'm saying come on
what the hell you think you're a little
bit too committed to that Taco Bell
now that would be fat shaming right yes
she says that the questions about her
weight gain accompanied by lizzo's
statements made after the South by
Southwest Festival gave Miss Davis the
impression that she needed to explain
her weight gain and disclose intimate
personal details about her life in order
to keep her job
it's all she felt she needed to yeah it
was thinly Veil yeah
it sounds like she's like yo what's
going on your performance is lacking and
she's like yo I'm doing all this stuff
is happening I gained some weight
whatever well maybe they're you know
this is just the uh initial complaint
right so they'll likely be
more evidence and the further filings
you have something to back that up
um I feel like it would be there if they
did uh conscious AI said I was a
professional dancer and they will
definitely correlate your commitment
with your body figure the whole sport is
about how you physically look on stage
okay
although I think a lot of our dancers
are
larger figured
if you look at like let's look at her
stance here
lizzo South
by Southwest
dance
let's take a look at their
yeah I mean this is
they have kind of similar body what are
we gonna do
[Music]
any money just saved me with that one
too
[Music]
yeah
again all right we're back we're just
tidying things up yeah yeah we're just
tidying up yeah making sure things are
tight
cleaning house
I don't want to be pushing the button
but I know today I'm on the I'm off the
rails and let's just keep this keep this
train going
but what I was saying I don't know if it
got cut
is because her dancers have a similar
body type to her the commitment angle
doesn't translate to you know losing
weight necessarily in my opinion
so I don't know
um
it says weight gain
she needed to explain her weight gain
yeah and disclose it she felt she needed
to right but gain yeah yeah yeah he was
just kidding about that oh whoa it was
it was buttoned anyway so oh well they
talk about an eating disorder later so I
understand
people want you to talk about this
banana thing the original okay the
original lawsuit accuses lizzo of
allegedly inviting cast members to take
turns touching the nude performers
inside the Amsterdam strip club she
allegedly encouraged catching dildos
launched from the performer's vaginas
holy [__] and eating bananas protruding
from the performer's vaginas that is
straight degeneracy let me tell you
about banana she's wild yeah I mean
that's pretty wild
well hold on let me read that again she
is encouraging
she's allegedly encouraging people to
catch dildos launched from the vaginas
can you launch a dildo out of a vagina
probably
just I get listen I don't have a vagina
I don't know the logistics of it but it
seems like a dildo would be pretty heavy
thing to launch these are talented
performers that's true
vagina take it back in the world yeah
imagining you have a vagina okay so
that's a strip club and they're
launching dildos
and shoving bananas in
[__] me
that's gross
yeah I mean look there's enough in here
that that is looks really bad for her
for sure
lizzo out here giving vegans a bad name
Dan come out as vegan please to reclaim
our good name
and to speak up for the voice too don't
stop at vegetarian the dairy cows and
eggs laying chicken need Liberation as
well Tim scholes cool thanks for the 50
bucks dude
you you're not you're not interested in
going vegan not really well the thing is
you can humanely Harvest uh
animal products like milk and yeah the
ones that wool sure
even beef there but it's very rare very
very very rare tell them to bring out
the whole ocean
bring out the whole damn ocean
all right let's move on past lizzo thank
you I only had to do the button five
times through that segment
now let's get to some real tea
um thank you to lizzo
thank you all right so up next
[Applause]
we have
our first ever
H3 True Crime segment
brought to you by
Lena
ayad
do you want to come sit here and uh are
you guys gonna sit here we're gonna
move to the couch like we did previously
correct yeah I'll come up there
up there so today's PowerPoint is about
um
one of the most uh prolific
Killers uh
I think ever
and it happened right here in La the The
Night Stalker
murder porn this guy was a real sick
twisted
mfer actually I should even give a a
trigger warning because
this is gonna uh it does include essay
really heinous
essay
and uh obviously murder but we're not
nothing too we're not showing anything
graphic
but we will be discussing it
yeah there's some blurred blurred photos
yeah
but if you guys like True Crime I guess
let's let's let's take a look also it
includes testimony from my parents who
were in La during the time kind of
interesting
gives it a little bit of a unique angle
there you go
thank you Olivia is we got the is the
glasses part of the True Crime Persona
well I what's I wear contacts normally
so these are my glasses yeah and I
figured I'd wear my glasses today
okay hi
just wait for everyone to get over here
thank you Cameron for the uh the
background Legend all right so as
everyone's kind of uh
coming together here oh we're in the uh
we're in prison
it's a lockdown huh
treada you're so cute what the hell
I shouldn't um move this up here at
least right to get it started
it turns out I'm 100 that'd be a [__]
turns out
okay we have complied with YouTube rules
we studied at the law the rules correct
we went into the the weeds
and we believe we are fully compliant
yes is there and there's well is there
any dildos being shot out of vaginas I
know we took that out
lizzo is not part is not safe Serena why
are you so cute
what the heck are we
I think so
how are we looking guys we're good
okay okay
Let's Roll
H3 True Crime as Ethan mentioned we're
going to be discussing the Night Stalker
one of the most horrific ethereal
killers in history
trigger warning the following
presentation contains sensitive content
and descriptions related to a notorious
criminal case viewer discretion is
advised
yes yes
yeah I like that you guys included
disclose that yes yes of course
also it's historical that's important
yes according to YouTube yes it is okay
fantastic so why this case
The Night Stalker is one of the most
horrific true crime stories in history
often described as a devil walking the
nice stalker Unleashed A Reign of Terror
over Los Angeles in the 1980s the nice
stalker is responsible for the murders
of at least 13 people with countless
others narrowly escaping his clutches
and attempted attacks and in addition to
these horrific crimes he committed 11
essays and committed 14 burglaries all
marked by a complete disregard for human
life what sets this case apart is not
only the sheer number of his victims but
also the audacity and brutality with
which he struck
his ability to terrorize multiple
victims in a single night with
Relentless savagery left communities
paralyzed with fear his teeth are
[__] crazy too yeah
apparently he smelled so bad yeah when
he was near people they would recoil
from the smell isn't that wild yeah
that's how any survivors that's how they
would describe him like [__] oh dude
the media frenzy surrounding the nice
Dockers crimes further high-end public
fear and captivated the nation the nice
stalker case highlighted the importance
of forensic evidence and cooperation
between different law enforcement
agencies and solving complex cases the
investigation also prompted improvements
in the sharing of information between
police departments and the use of
emerging Technologies in criminal
investigation
the nightstalker's reign of terror
permeated popular culture leaving an
imprint on books movies and music
and one example of his influence on pop
culture is the fact that he's a
recurring character on the show American
Horror Story I watched that season well
also the dude he tattooed the pentagram
on his palm yeah and you see that all
over the place like the hand pentagram
on the top or bottom of it that's he's
so crazy dude he's evil
there it is
so Friends of the show recount their
experiences living in Southern
California during the terrifying era of
the Night Stalker
and I remember reading about all this
stuff on the news it was really scary
because this guy killed arbitrarily I
mean he killed women he killed men he
raped he stole so it certainly induced a
sense of paranoia and fear in the city
in general killings seemed to be so
Random uh he tortured women but then
upon occasion killed and tortured men
also so there seemed to be uh you know
no pattern there at all man it was scary
I didn't want to go out at night you
know when someone's on the loose and you
don't know who it is and they haven't
caught it it's it's kind of frightening
this guy ruined my summer of 1985 this
[__] scum [__] I'm a child and this
a-hole just terrorized the city of Los
Angeles for months I think that summer I
could not sleep with my window open
because I was terrified he was going to
crawl through because he was abducting
children he was killing old people he
was doing stuff to everybody yeah
and he ruined AC DC if I may say so
myself this guy's a real knucklehead
one thing I'm curious about because you
don't really see this type of thing
happen anymore of like a serial killer
running around shutting down like a
whole city I wonder is it just like a
forensic thing where police
investigation has got so much better
that these people can't get away with it
no that's a huge part of it yeah
definitely I mean this guy was throwing
up he was coming like on the scene for
no reason ejaculating ejaculating
he was puking yeah because he's a demon
bro yeah like
so he definitely left DNA evidence but
there was no way to test it at the time
yeah so yeah we're not because I'm
obsessed with this true crime so
whenever I watch DNA in 2020 it's all
like
we didn't we didn't have the ability to
uh test the DNA from one Speck of human
skin and now
it's not that easy to be serial killer
yeah you aren't solving a bunch of
[__] yeah
there's actually more stuff
it's a bad time to be serial killer
serial killer folks
a good time to be a cereal eater oh yeah
I love cereal the flavors have never
been better I like your charms all
different flavors
so like they mentioned people in La were
just terrified and it was like a real
life Boogeyman was on the loose
[Music]
and I remember reading about
the approach so in an effort to provide
an immersive experience we have decided
to hold back the identity and the name
of the Night Stalker until the end of
the presentation this will allow you the
audience to follow the investigation
just as investigators did piecing
together the clues and unraveling the
mystery we will explore the timeline of
the nightstalkers crimes highlighting
key events and notable incidents
step by step we'll delve into the
investigation's progress the challenges
faced and the Strategies employed to
track down the notorious pillar
so yes setting the scene this took place
in La in 1984 to 1985.
and here's a little video of La as I say
this next part
so la is a significant character into
sort of the Night Stalker and the 1980s
was an exciting time royalty free yeah
you checked that yeah thank you with
tons of innovation and creativity
California embodied this idea of
achieving your dream are you reading
something huh no I have notes it's like
straight out of the the pamphlet that's
the point yeah no so you have you have
the beaches you guys are gonna [__] up
my train of thought you have and I only
have a certain amount of time because
the video's gonna run out yeah so you
had the beaches you had uh Hollywood and
you know there was a Renaissance going
on in both music and film you had uh
directors being more experimental you
head back to the Future come out you had
Ghostbusters you had um New Wave you had
hip hop just being born you had uh
artists performing at the Rock scene the
Troubadour and they would later go on to
become Legends yeah like that there was
a lot going on at the time and it was a
very exciting time of expression and uh
yeah around the world La seemed like the
place to go to achieve your dreams dude
were people really just doing that down
at Venice yeah that's so wild
dude it was a you we were living in a
utopian uh Dreamscape where people were
on four-wheel skates doing choreographed
dances
yeah a lot of people had their their
doors unlocked even as these crimes were
being committed a lot of people like it
took them time to adjust to locking like
their back doors wow
um but yeah beneath the Passat of Assad
there is a dark past associated with LA
uh because so many people move out here
from back home you know wherever they're
from uh it's just this big mix of people
and so you have people you know like
dating back to 1947 Elizabeth Short who
was uh brutally murdered uh she was an
aspiring actress
and uh you guys may have heard of her as
the Black Dahlia
um which was a pretty [__] up case but
also you have uh the Hillside Strangler
amongst other things like what happened
at the Cecil hotel and the uh
the death of uh sorry I was family
enough from Cecil uh Elisa lamb Lisa
lamb yeah maybe if we maybe if people
stop giving them these cool ass
nicknames they stop killing people yeah
I agree with that they get like the
coolest [__] nicknames dude the
Hillside Strangler yeah The Night
Stalker love and I stayed at the hotel
that the Black Dahlia Murder happened at
oh no way right up the street from the
hotel season yeah Hotel Cecil is the
most cursed place now have you seen it
recently they paint they painted it
white and put a big blue heart on it so
it's like a nice try yeah they're trying
really hard you can't paint a piece of
[__] right well also they transformed it
to low-income housing so we don't want
to stay there I'm like hell no but it
might be a segment I don't think you can
I tried I wouldn't I swear to God I
wouldn't I won and I'm like [__] that no
don't go there but also um along the
lines of uh the dark pass is also
important to note that
the size of La is very important because
the way that uh because of how big it is
and the way that the jurisdictions are
split up you have a bunch of different
departments uh working in LA and that
means that certain information is
withheld
um because everyone wants to solve the
cases everyone wants to be the heroes
and there's just bad communication so
that allowed for people like The Night
Stalker to get around for so long
without being caught
so yeah we talked about where this story
takes place now let's talk about who our
story will be following
so we have three main players we have
Gil Korea
Korea I cannot get his last name right
Gail Carrillo I know that guy from
watching all the [__] shows yeah yeah
he's talked about this there's you know
obviously there was a Netflix
documentary that came out recently that
sparked interest in this case
um but yeah Gil and Frank Salerno and
The Night Stalker so let's start with
Gill
detective Gil Carrillo is uh Carrillo
sorry a homicide detective so this uh
cop was the youngest cop in the division
the youngest investigator and he's from
the streets he has a background
um that involved gang violence he grew
up in a neighborhood with gang violence
and his different perspective and his
different way of looking at this case is
really crucial in solving it
our second comp is detective Frank
Salerno Frank Salerno was this badass
like uh Top Cop who was known for being
one of the LA Bulldogs which was this
group of investigators that were known
to solve these unsolvable cases like the
Hillside Strangler uh he was involved in
that and he was looked up to and
respected by many other cops including
Gill
so let's just get into the investigation
is wait was it Philip DeFranco in the
Night Stalker well he may come back into
no I'm kidding but I actually made that
with uh
the Photoshop AI oh you just said put a
pentagram on Phillips hand yeah there's
no hand there yeah I just said give him
a pentagram and a hand oh wow that's
awesome sorry Phil
okay our investigation begins on March
17 1985 and this takes place in Rosemead
California
case one Dale okazaki he was 34 years
old shot in the forehead at her home
here's what happened that night Dale's
roommate 22 year old Maria Hernandez
arrived home and pulled into her garage
she began to walk inside when someone
slapped the top of her car to get her
attention so she would turn around when
she turned to see what made the noise a
man shot her with a handgun
luckily the bullet ricocheted off her
keys he was holding as she lifted her
hands to protect herself Maria played
dead until the suspect flipped the scene
and then she escaped
did it not it didn't hit her no so when
but he held up the gun and then she put
her hands up like this to protect
herself and she was holding her keys no
way yeah so the keys yeah yeah that's
straight affecting her there's yeah
that's crazy there's some aspects of the
story that are so insane
um I'll let you continue on on spoiling
fan that seems fake like this is a movie
yeah well there's this luck for real
yeah her specifically
actually go ahead I don't want to spoil
Dale okazaki who's inside the home
here's the gunshot and hides behind the
counter in her kitchen after it got
quiet ale peeked over the counter and
then was shot in the forehead by the
suspect
Maria had already escaped but after
hearing another gunshot which is the
shot that killed Dale she got worried
about her body and decided to go back
I'm leaving everyone this is straight up
like scream plot yeah
so this time she goes to the front
entrance instead of the garage she runs
into the suspect again and she says
something like you already shot me once
do you really need to shoot me again the
suspect looked at her he put his gun
down to his side and then just casually
walked away did that really happen
he lived to tell the tale
that's nuts dude
so later that night Gil arrives on the
scene he begins the investigation by
having the photographer take photos of
the crime while investigating the crime
scene the mother of Maria Hernandez
arrives and asks to speak to go he calls
Gil by his full name and says it's me
Pauline Gill is in is then shocked to
realize that Maria's mom is his old
neighbor who lived Three Doors Down from
him growing up so the case felt close to
home for Gill
yeah and that's kind of amazing that and
then because no one calls him uh Gilbert
his real name and then yeah when he was
called out he recognized Maria's mom
being from the same neighborhood
so the fact that Gil was also a father
tied into this and he's from the same
neighborhood as one of the first victims
while Maria Hernandez was in the
hospital she gave a description of the
suspect for a police sketch and that's
the drawing they come came up with
spot on
I've never seen a police guy that
actually looks right
March 18 1985 day two of the
investigation
we have case two thylie and you age 30.
her last words were reportedly help me
and this took place in Monterey Park
investigators found out that 40 minutes
after Dale was murdered there was
another attack in Monterey Park a young
Asian girl got pulled out of her car and
shot for no apparent reason he didn't
take the car he just left yeah it's
important that investigators know the
race of the suspect because they want to
see if there's some sort of Mo or
reoccurring uh
you know
feature of the victims
so the evidence we find here is a 22
caliber gun which is a same caliber
weapon that was used in the previous
murder but we can't say it's a match for
sure because 22s are very common
Chet said the drawing looks like Gill
the cup
reminded Gill of a class he took about
sex crime and he remembered a certain
deviency that says I'd like to see a
frightened look on your face I want to
see you scared that's what really gets
me turned on
this is what the suspect did with both
Maria and Dale with Maria the suspect
slapped the top of her car to make a
noise and get her attention so that he
could see her face and with Dale he
waited until she peeked over the
countertop to shoot her yeah he was he
was standing there he was he was he got
quiet too he didn't move wait until she
came up so she looked him in the eye and
then he shot her that's like a
Counter-Strike play yeah
that's right he was camping
now in this now in this case the suspect
could have could have shot xylene in her
car but instead he dragged her out
before shooting her so he could see the
fear that she had
these correlations are what First Blood
Guild to thinking that these murders may
have been committed by the same guy
March 27 1985 this is day 10 of the
investigation
there was a double murder in Whittier
just a few days later
the suspect got in the house through an
open bathroom window
Vincent cesara 64 years old was found
dead on the couch with a gunshot to his
head once again a 22 was used his wife
Maxine was found dead in the bed she was
graped and I say grape he was graped and
had several
grapes I don't know yeah okay so she was
R worded and had several stab wounds
above the vagina the suspect also caught
her eyes out and took them with him
their bodies were found by their son
Peter when police arrived the house was
ransacked and there was forty thousand
dollars worth of jewelry stolen and wait
by the police no no by the suspect when
the police arrived they found that 40K
was missing the house was ransacked
before the police arrived right okay so
not only murder but there's also
burglary and this case specifically a
detail Lena found that wasn't in the
documentary actually is that uh they had
a shotgun in the home yeah a couple did
and so once Maxine heard the gunshot
that killed her husband she went to
their bedroom she grabbed their shotgun
from underneath the bed and she pointed
it at him she clicked she pulled the
trigger and it was unloaded so maybe
that's why he was like so vicious with
her and like took her eyes out that
probably really upset him he I think I
I'm no expert but yeah my guess was that
he he's
he scared him and so he was very brutal
with her because of that
because you don't see that again with
the eyes
my knowledge
the importance of this case is that they
found a size 12 shoe print at the point
of entry
so the evidence we have here a 22
caliber gun
ransacked home and now we have the shoe
print
around this time Gil was looking at
other cases in nearby areas and one that
stood out to him was the kidnapping of
Anastasia haronas a six-year-old girl
the suspect broke in through a window
and kidnapped Anastasia from her bed in
the middle of the night he intimidated
the girl with the gun and made her get
into a duffel bag and stay quiet he took
her back to the place where he was
staying essayed her and then put her
back in the duffel bag and into the car
he dropped her off at a gas station and
told her to go inside and call 9-1-1 so
her family could come get her
foreign
so at the time there was numerous like
child abductions and even though it
wasn't Gill's Department because he's
homicide and this is uh you know child
abductions he was still just listening
to all the cases that were coming in and
uh he noticed that the description
including uh the smell of uh the suspect
was similar and some of the police
sketches given by the children and by
the first victim was similar and so he
started to think that possibly this was
the same guy that was abducting these
children and committing these murders
and at the time this hasn't been
documented before and a lot of people
thought he was insane a lot of people
thought he was just a young cop that was
trying to make a name for himself just
trying to get attention and everyone
just basically laughed off his theory
that this may have been the same guy
on April 10 1985 this is day 24 of the
investigation
bill went to a meeting with other
departments to share information they
laughed at his theory that the crime
spree was the work of one killer he was
dismissed and even laughed at why'd they
laugh at him
just because it was never done before it
was it was they literally thought he was
just pulling it out of his ass just to
start to make a name for himself because
he was a young cop coming in but again I
think that's where him coming from the
streets and having a different
background allowed him to see this case
differently
they didn't think it was possible for
someone to be attacking adults like that
and then also molesting kids but letting
them go right he was murdered he's
viciously murdering these adults but
letting the kids go
there's a description in general the the
drawings and then the uh the smell was
noted as well you know how they gave him
like the name Night Stalker and I'm sure
he loved it could have called him the
stinky [__] yeah
so May 14 1985 this is day 58 of the
investigation
the police get a call from a man named
William doy he's 66 years old who was
shot and dying he was dead by the time
police arrived but that phone call ended
up saving his wife's life the police
found his wife badly beaten she had on
bum cuffs her right thumb was bleeding
badly due to her ripping her thumbs
apart trying to free herself dumb coughs
yeah the cops never like saw that before
what do you even get phone calls so he
was big on uh discovering new ways of
torturing people at some point we'll
talk about it later he goes to a library
and actually like checks out books on
human torture what is a thumb cuff
it's more painful oh yeah
probably easy to break you
yeah
and just a note here the investigators
knew the suspect was following the media
coverage of what was going on because
following this case all the crime scenes
after that had the phone lines ripped
out so he didn't want to want it to
happen again where one of the victims
could call the police
um the evidence we have here a 22
caliber was used to kill the male thumb
cup thumb cup slash unusual weapon the
homeless ransacked for valuables and we
have the immediate killing of the male
and assault on the female
yeah in terms of physical evidence
there's not much there's a link in them
all besides that at 22 is used but
that's like the most commonly used gun
so
around this time
Paul from another officer who shares a
footprint of the suspect involved in the
Abduction of an eight-year-old who is
kidnapped and taken to a construction
site and assaulted and then set free
the construction site had poured
concrete that day which is what
preserved the footprint Gil takes a look
at the footprint and immediately
recognizes it as a similar footprint to
what was found at the zazara crime scene
however the problem was that when Gill
called the other department they handled
the crime scene they said the shoe print
they had was a size 10 not a size 12
which is what um Gill had this was one
of the many mistakes made by the police
the cop had put his own shoe size 10 on
it and thought it was the same after
Gill pushed back he found out that the
cop was wearing wing tip shoes which
means the cop's measurement was wrong
and the shoe and the shoe size did
actually match the one from the cesara
case yeah so like this cop just put his
foot up and that's how he measured it
and this is one of the many instances of
bad uh cop detective work I mean you
know this case is unique because you
have some of the best in terms of like
Gill and Frank but on the other hand
from other departments there's a lot of
stupid [__] like this and he had a push
back a lot to get other departments to
help in simple stuff like this and then
he eventually found out it was a
matching shoe print and at this point is
when Frank started to believe Gil's
theory that maybe it's the same guy
yeah they'll comment thread with all
these is that there's just really
[__] horrible police and all these
True Crime
just a lazy dumb
morons
after this is there music playing to
yeah yeah I can't hear it can you just
turn it up a little bit so I can hear it
um at this point Frank asked Gail to be
his partner and everyone was shocked in
the department because Frank was this
legendary cop and then Gil was just this
uh young detective who didn't have a lot
of experience but Frank was able to
recognize that gill had was seeing the
case in a different light and was
exactly who he needed
um and you know Gil was ecstatic Frank
was a hero of Harry's it's kind of like
you hiring me Ethan it was it was a big
deal for him you know uh many people
were surprised and uh yeah I've already
said that yeah but it was this was
exactly the pairing that was needed to
solve this case
here in 28 1985 this is day 103 of the
investigation
we have Patty Higgins age 32. this is
the first case that Frank and go had
together he was violently murdered he
slit her throat and then stabbed her in
the Slash
stabbed her and oh oh I see in the same
place where he slips yeah yeah it's
really awful
and then July 2nd this is only four days
since that last murder
we have Mary Louise Cannon aged 75. this
was another violent murder that happened
just a few miles away in Arcadia after
beating her with the lamp he used a
knife from her kitchen to Slit her
throat in a very similar way that he did
to Patty Higgins
so the link between the these two cases
was the slit and stab throat wound
and yeah you could see that he starts to
become more and more prevalent as to how
many times you know how many victims
within a certain amount of time and you
can see the where these crimes are
taking place is starting to spread out
more as well
July 5 1985
day 110 of the investigation
we have Whitney Bennett 16 years old
the next case occurred only three days
later in Sierra Madre which is very
close to Arcadia the victim survived but
didn't remember anything he was beaten
in her sleep with a tire iron and then
strangled with the telephone cord the
bedroom was a mess he woke up with 42
inches of lacerations and skull
fractures
a fabric marked with blood was found on
the windowsill which meant the suspect
was wearing gloves this aligned with
previous crime scenes because they were
they weren't able to find any
fingerprints before
they also found a bloody shoe print on
the comforter that matched the shoe
print from the zizara case and the
construction site
yeah but she survived a fabric marked
Anto it means that he was wearing gloves
so no he stepped he's he had blood on
his shoe and he stepped on I think he's
on the next yeah that one's separate
there was so there's a comforter that he
left the shoe print on and then the
evidence from the windowsill showed that
he's wearing gloves yeah because the
window is open and there was no
fingerprints once again
so after finding the bloody shoe print
on the comforter Frank was fully in
agreement with Gill that this was the
same guy with Frank vouching for Gill's
Theory the police department then
started to finally take it seriously
yeah with Frank's Frank uh endorsing him
everyone started getting on board
yeah
literally
so the evidence we have here that linked
it to the previous cases we have the
ransacked room use of gloves and no
fingerprints and of course the shoe
print
I wonder if in the history of Sweden
ever there's ever anything
like anything even close to this
probably not I mean I bet there is every
country has their their serial killers
Google that dude someone Google that
yeah worst serial killer in Sweden he's
out there the meatball murderer
love shows up oh my God oh my God
oh [__] wait we have breaking news
we just got a response from the day love
the day like ourselves
[Applause]
oh wow wait what do I make of that seems
awesome really nice yeah so can I
yeah the gist of it he says he's a fan
of the show
but it's not his place notest place to
get involved yeah okay but family so
he's a cousin he said he doesn't miss a
show wow
shout out my friend maybe you can put it
put a good word in for your cousin
tell them they're not bad dudes say
we'll give them tick tocks love Yeah
nope yes
love you love ya so taking a look back
at the case up to this point one of the
factories I made it so hard was that
there was no mo and no pattern which
made him more terrifying because anyone
regardless of age race or gender can be
a victim yeah and
I think it's important to emphasize on
that like with other cases you know it
would cause fear a lot of times like
with the Hillside Strangler for example
it'd be women who are terrified and like
there was like uh the police were
telling women they shouldn't be walking
around alone at night but in this case
everyone kids were [__] terrified men
and women everyone
July 6 day 111
there was an attempted break-in in Pico
Lorraine Rodriguez was sleeping on the
couch and woke up after hearing a window
open she called out to her husband to
check the House John who's a cop grabbed
his gun and searched the House John
finds an open window he looks outside
and sees a shoe print that was perfectly
imprinted into the dirt due to the
pressure that was needed to lift the
window he called the police and when
Gill arrived he realized the print was
an exact match
now that they have a detailed shoe print
they were able to go around looking for
what type of shoe it was they find out
eventually that it's an Avia shoe and
yes they got really lucky with that
because this is one of the rarest shoes
you could have it was still a new shoe
and um
they found out the maker of the shoe and
then they went to go speak to the
creator of it uh Jerry's sub uh subfield
and he was able to provide them with
information including the sales records
and luckily this is insane that they got
so lucky with this they were able to
determine that only six pairs of that
shoe were manufactured in that size
about five of them were sent to Arizona
and only one came to La so exclusive
shoes exclusive
no no no no no no they were just new
they were cheap because they were new
yeah they were like can we buy these
sneakers I guarantee that these probably
have some like crazy cult following I
wonder it's probably an Evidence Locker
yeah no nothing not the sneakers not his
sneakers they know where they are no so
we'll get to that what's the size 11 11.
perfect Zach would you wear those
I know you're a sneakerhead Zach would
you wear those fours
[Music]
by the way Swedish serial killer 30
murders at least that's pretty good
that's pretty good dad shout out to
student buddy was that like Stuart
better you guys go to school together uh
have you heard the name let's do
everybody wrong no oh yeah I mean it
rings a bell actually it does
it sounds pretty juicy yeah anyway a
story for another time yeah maybe
yeah so if they find uh the perpetrator
wearing the shoes they know they got the
guy and so as more information starts to
come in they're able to look back at
older faces and they basically found
um lots of similarities between uh
the investigation so far in a previous
case that took place a month prior to
identifying the shoe so it would
involved two sisters who were in their
80s living in Monrovia
um the suspected from the back door tied
them off the electrical tape uh did all
the usual nasty [__]
um and after he assaulted and beat them
to death with a hammer yeah
he sat down to have a snack
he just said like it was nothing
um got a carb up yeah and your
pentagrams on the victim's leg and also
on the bedroom wall yeah and there was
an alarm clock uh they had a partial
shoe print so when he went to rip out
the wire from the or the cable from the
alarm clock to tie them up with he
stepped on it and it was a matching shoe
print yeah
yeah it was like an old I think it's in
the next slide yeah you see on the
bottom right that's interesting go ahead
sorry for him to
feel as if he has the time to sit down
and eat a snack yeah it's right here
he's getting very cocky oh yeah after
like yeah he viciously attacked these
women and then he took a moment to pause
and and sit down and
he had the Mountain Dew so we got
Mountain Dew oh [__] what number was
this event it's going all night
um I'm not sure exactly because the way
that it's lined up I think it's roughly
I'd say this is about probably like
eight or I bought both questions the
number what number murder This was oh um
yeah it's hard to line up but we this
this murder occurred um a month before
this is our appealing yeah I think this
is the case I could be wrong where after
eating he just puked on the carpet and
then coming up okay by the way coming up
the Golden State killer used to do the
same thing he would
he would tie up women and then in the
middle of the assault he would go
through their kitchen and hang out in
their house for hours
that's so wild
so it's a thing yeah it's like a power
thing I think yeah and they just I they
don't feel what they're doing like I
don't know I
well they're not they don't feel things
like Wheatfield yeah they lack the
empathy that a normal human does
so shortly after there's an attempt at
kidnapping an Eagle Rock the girl fought
back so the suspect bled while fleeing
he convinced a traffic violation and
gets pulled over without a license a cop
goes back to his bike to write a
citation and the suspect overhears the
cops radio which is describing the car
he's in and talking about the attempted
kidnapping
though he drew a pentagram on the hood
of the car and then just ran away
the police later find out that that car
he was driving was stolen
the car gets impounded Dylan Frank try
to get prints on it but another
department says they'll handle it which
they never do this causes investigators
to lose another potential lead that's so
yeah multiple [__] ups that could have
been huge oh it's we're gonna yeah it
we'll we'll Circle back to this The Thin
Blue Line baby the only thing that
stands between us and Chaos yeah
apparently
July 7 1985 this would be day 112.
though Gill gets a call from Linda
Arthur who is a colleague he tells him
that her neighbor just got R worded
Linda had friends over and was hanging
out in the hot tub until around 3 A.M
she goes to bed shortly after when one
of her friends wakes her up and says
someone is calling your name from
outside it was her neighbor Sophie
Dickman who was 63 years old she tells
Linda that she'd been robbed are worded
and tied up to her bed the victim said
the attacker ransacked her home and then
made her swear on Satan that she didn't
have any valuables the suspect also an
interesting thing is that the suspect
entered her home from the cat door
because Sophie actually skinny Legend
yeah
she actually had her doors and windows
locked in the previous cases they didn't
that's so small yeah cat doors that's
really small he's a [__]
um so it turns out also just to
emphasize that
this was so close to home already Gila
like it affected so many people in the
city besides the fear
um hey Gill for example he you know the
mom of the first victim one of the first
victims he knew growing up and now this
is a co-worker whose neighbor a close
friend and co-worker whose neighbor was
our worded and attacked by him and then
it turns out that earlier that night a
woman named Joyce Nelson was killed in
her home she was only five two roughly
100 pounds and a beloved grandmother she
was found by her son uh beaten and dead
in her room she fought back to stop him
from outwarding her and this caused him
to get angry and like brutally beat her
and even stomp her on the side of the
head leaving a footprint he didn't
fulfill his sexual need with her so he
went a mile away and assaulted the
previous person we were talking about
Sophie Dickman
[Music]
um also a matching shoe print was found
at the concrete nearby
yeah this police are [__] dumb like
he went down the street and committed
another crime yeah same night afterwards
right now please don't show it morons
so these attacks happen in Monterey Park
again
how far away were the two crime scenes
so if you go back all right it was
number six and seven so you can see that
line right there Monterey Park oh so
it's not the same neighborhood it seems
no not the same time cannot get over how
many people could have been
saved yeah yeah if the police had just
done their job dude it's every True
Crime Story it's like only through
police incompetency and not just like a
little competency like sheer
mind-numbing disregard for human life
yeah just yeah so are we still before
the shoe no this is after the shoot got
found now so nothing ever happened with
that so they just know what the shoe is
so basically if they find the person who
has those shoes for for any crime for
stealing for whatever it is if they find
someone wearing those shoes that's their
guy they didn't get like credit card
um I think they found the sales receipt
uh but it didn't it wasn't able to link
it any further as paid cash yeah yeah
okay but also it's a big clue for them
because
become scene that has a print they know
it's
this is when things really start to like
ramp up because now you had five cases
in only 10 days and this got all the
newspapers talking about all the media
they started to notice that Gill and
Frank were arriving at the same crime
scenes and they didn't want the media to
know that yet they didn't want them to
know that they thought it was the same
guy but uh
yeah around this time the media started
to pay attention and uh
sorry yeah so moving on Laurel Erickson
uh who was a reporter at the time she
calls Frank
and she says um
so what can you tell me about the shoe
somehow she found out about basically
the only clue that they had and they
were pissed off like Gil wanted to
arrest her for like obstructing justice
because she didn't give a [__] she just
wanted to get the story and so the
police chief called her and they worked
out a deal she said I won't I won't say
anything about the shoe if you do an
exclusive interview with me so they
talked to Gill and Frank and they were
able to get an exclusive walking out the
back of the station
uh this or she was able to six-year-old
this is what she got say anything my tip
Salerno has been working homicide for
almost a decade he and his partner 35
year old Gil Carrillo have too much
invested too much at stake this time
it's the walk-in killer seven bodies
beaten stabbed or shot last time it was
the Hillside Strangler Kenneth Bianchi
10 girls or women murdered
Solano says that case is going to be a
great advantage in cracking this one
serial killers have one thing in common
they're generally in a Serial murder uh
what occurs is they might relocate but
they don't stop killing until they're
either caught or imprisoned or killed
Salado has worked round the clock for
the last month and a half taking only
one day off for his son's wedding his
co-workers call him a cops detective
Frank overlooks nothing you'd be
surprised how thorough he is
a friend at all Salerno is overseeing
the work of more than four dozen
investigators from local police agencies
plus two FBI psychologists who are
sifting through evidence and tips from
the public Salerno and Cabrillo have a
lot of Clues to cross-index authorities
say calls from the San Gabriel and San
Fernando valleys have shot up 50 percent
people afraid of the walk-in killer that
one's a little better Sergeant has one
new piece of information FBI Specialists
called in to develop a psychological
profile of the criminal has completed
their work that's all she got yeah
that's a good deal yeah for them sure
yeah
um so July 9th this is day 114
investigation and so Gil and Frank end
up following up on that car that was
supposed to be scanned for Prince and
turns out that the other department
didn't scan it for print and ended up
raining or whatever and they were gone
they're washed away surprise so inside
the car they found a business card for a
uh dental office in Chinatown and
whoever the suspect was was at the
dentist on July 3rd so when they got
there on July 9th they had missed him by
five days so if they would have
uh
shown this if they would have actually
done their job and looked at the
fingerprints and looked inside the car
they would have found that card let's go
LAPD still yeah so since then they had
three more baby they had three more
victims of the Night Stalker that could
have been prevented if it weren't for
bad police work
um so while following up with the
dentist they found out that the patient
given a fake name of Richard Mena and a
fake address uh guilt obtained his
dental records and share it with a close
friend who's a dentist and that dentist
told Gail that he'll be back in for sure
whatever's wrong with his teeth he'll be
back in for sure because it's bad
and so
um
what they did is they installed 24-hour
surveillance they had people inside the
dentist uh office waiting for him to
show up and they did this for a few days
and then an executive in the police
department thought they were wasting
Resources by having two guys on
surveillance so they called him off and
in place of the surveillance team they
put a button a panic button so if he
comes in the dentist could push the
button the first day that they called
the surveillance team off
um the suspect walked in let's go lap
and they they hit the alarm and it
didn't work so let's go later that day
they later that day the dentist called
Gill and says how come you guys didn't
come and he goes what do you mean and uh
yeah he said I was hitting the alarm but
no one came in damn what's the budget of
the LAPD
2 billion let's oh wow go right now
so July 20 1985 the next crime scene
takes place in Glendale California
and so mind you this is this this is
after the second instance where they
could have easily caught him like yeah
this is another attack on an elderly
couple Max and Leela needing they were
found dead by their daughter both had
been shot with a 22 the suspect entered
the pool gate and then entered their
home through uh through the back door
and to this day a lot of these like uh
houses where where these victims lived
is like covered by like big trees or a
big fence they had to put because of
like the the spectacle of this crime
like people still drive by and like want
to see the house and stuff it's wild
these are just some photos from that
crime scene you can see he went through
ransacked their home also
on the following night another crime
occurred in Sun Valley the suspect went
in through the rare sliding door that
was left unlocked the suspect then went
to the bedroom and shot the father
janeirong Covenant he was 32 years old
after killing him the suspect then
essayed his wife and their
eight-year-old son yeah and that's one
of the reoccurring things that he does
and so brutal is he would he would kill
the husband and then
the the wife after knowing her husband
was just killed then had to go through
his torture whatever it was
dude he was such a sick [__] he was
saying kids he didn't care the gender
the age it was like just disgusting yeah
so vile like I was so [__] vile man
God damn this case showed that all the
this case showed all the clues that
we've seen in the previous cases we have
the VSU print the 22 caliber gun and the
mo that he was executing the mail and
essaying the female the wife gave a good
description for a composite drawing and
this is a drawing that they end up going
public with that one's good I think yeah
so does the suspect at this point is he
aware that his teeth are a big
identifier I don't think he knows
anything about the Denver he doesn't
know anything about the dentist office
and most importantly he doesn't know
about the shoe because that's their main
like because 22 is common there's a lot
of things in here that are common the vs
shoe is the only thing that will
directly link him without a doubt but if
you're talking about the drawings and
stuff and the descriptions he is
following the the media's coverage of
what's going on I wonder if he's like
these teeth are like horrible I need to
blend in more yeah I don't think he
cares I think he's just like I need some
meth yeah maybe dude if I ever get
mugged or something I'm gonna Photoshop
the perfect yeah
so August 6th
day 142 of the investigation
two people were shot in Northridge Chris
and Virginia Peterson were both shot in
the head but survived Chris got up and
chased the killer out of the house a
different gun was used this time it was
a 25 caliber and the bullet had a red
primer on it which the crime lab said it
was uncommon and meant that this was an
older type of ammunition
two people shot in the head yeah yeah I
know and he chased him out too yeah but
it doesn't look like did the bullet even
puncture their skin like what am I
looking at yeah I think it grazed them I
was confused by the
yeah yeah both of them
he got chased out after being shot in
the head that's pretty yeah yeah it's
pretty badass yeah you can see it the
the entrance over here where it's a
bunch of blood splatter from them
running when I first read about this
case I was afraid because I'm like now
he's gonna feel like
whatever you want to call it humiliated
for being chased out and he's just gonna
be even worse or you know commit
multiple crimes now
so it was around this time that the
herald examiner called him the Night
Stalker
he gets his name officially awesome good
job Harold examiner sick [__] name
his super villain name is great let's
get him a cape
August 8 day 144
a crime occurred in Diamond Bar which
was a few minutes away from Gil's house
in Rowland Heights after this crime
Gil's wife decided that she and the kids
would leave home and not come back until
the case was solved Bill arrived at the
crime scene first since he lived so
close the point of entry was the rear
door there was a happy end honeydew
melon on the counter famed 25 caliber
red primer ammunition was used from the
Peterson case and the victim was Elias
35 years old he was Sean killed and then
his wife was essayed he said the suspect
told her don't look at me and she said I
swear to God I won't he said don't swear
to God swear to Satan
so cringe yeah yeah atheist loser
um so this was right around the corner
from Gill's house yeah and Gill's family
left because they were scared right yeah
they're finding out who if the killer
found out who was investigating him well
yeah because Laurel Ericksons you put
out that story so now people knew that
who the investigators were Frank said
even Frank said that was the only time
in his life throughout all of his
investigations that he actually slept
with a gun because he was terrified so
that was actually really [__] up
though yeah
yeah and so
um
at this crime scene he was hearing uh
different cops talk from different
departments and everything they were
saying was bad they were just talking
bad information
and uh he'll correct them and said no
what you guys are saying is completely
wrong about this suspect and he realized
how like the communication was so
horrible so he took the initiative to
make a private video just for other
police departments sharing everything
that he had he wasn't focused on like
solving the carry like he didn't want
the credit he he put out this video just
to help the other departments all be on
the same page to help solve this case
um which was a you know a big thing at
the time
I'm a big fan of guilt he's the man for
sure
so um now we have Frank balzan who is in
San Francisco a Police Inspector there
and his partner were called to a crime
scene Peter Pan 66 years old Peter Pants
yeah yeah
what sorry who the [__] wait Peter oh
is he he's he's Chinese or something
yeah yeah okay so he moved to America
and then he's Peter Pan yeah he was a
nobody with a normal name and now he's
Peter Pan is that's a huge name yeah
you should
so yeah not a happy ending for our Peter
it turns out Peter Pan does not stay
young forever very tragic he was shot in
the head in his bed his wife Barbara was
R worded and shot in the head but still
had a pulse and was taken to the
hospital the scene was grotesque the
suspect ate food from the refrigerator
regurgitated on the kitchen floor and
then masturbated on the living room
carpet what the [__] and carved a
pentagram on the wall
the details of the case caught the
attention of the Glendale Police
Department oh they noticed it now yep
finally and hey you think this is a
little unusual this crime scene this is
getting should we tell someone about
this I think it was especially the
pentagram yeah that stood out to them
not the puke the semen the double murder
the dead body yeah
okay the pentagram so they suggested
that they do a ballistics check and they
check the ammunition and it had the same
red primer on it which was which they've
been linking to The Night Stalker
so Gill and Frank immediately fly to San
Francisco They investigate the crime
scene and later briefed the San
Francisco police on everything they know
including the VSU they emphasized the
importance of keeping
um info about the shoe completely
private and so now because this happened
all the way in San Francisco the whole
state was terrified because they're like
he's going everywhere now it's not just
LA and so yeah they they shared all the
information and they emphasized that
really all they really had was the Via
shoe unfortunately shortly after this
murder the clue about the shoe print was
leaked does anyone know who leaked it
it's the reporter right yeah that's what
I'm nope it's not the blonde lady
someone we've talked about on the show
already
Diane find cheaply take that dummy are
you kidding me
Dianne Feinstein what
yep so how did she do that she was the
mayor at the time in San Francisco
she wanted to be the one to uh talk
about this to you know for for her
political career and um right it's just
it's just a political move because we're
more political yep and she announced a
10K reward we have to bring this guy to
Justice
um she revealed all the vital leaves
they had including the ammunition and
most importantly the shoe print that
they have why what's why even say that
you dummy yeah some of the San Francisco
police allege that the chief never told
the mayor not to share them oh [__]
[__] yeah they yeah after the fact
because they're playing cover-up 100 she
knew she wanted to be the person that
was like she's taking credit for all
their investors exact words exactly yeah
[__] you retired she spills [__]
everything up dumb ass in a wheelchair
shame ballistics on I understand more
than a dozen murders uh committed in
Southern California and there's holding
the very same flyer that we said was for
law enforcement only and she's talking
about the Avia Shoes she's talking about
a vehicle description she's talking
about weapons
[Music]
it was
an understatement
the uh so after she did that the shoe
was never recovered never found it after
that recovered he's like oh yo shout out
all right
did she get a lot of [__] for this
I don't know law enforcement yeah from
La definitely like Frank and Gil were
pissed they didn't want to go back into
work and then so the police chief like
they were like drinking at the bar they
were pissed off and the police chief is
like come down to the station I'm gonna
start I'm gonna make a press conference
and police chief basically like called
her out like embarrassed her just died
yeah Ramirez ended up staying in prison
that when they asked him about the BSU
he said he threw them over the Golden
Gate Bridge
very symbolic just for you girl my next
murders are are dedicated to you
now we're in Mission Viejo which is in
Orange County we're outside of La now
he's expanding a little more Bill Karns
29 years old was shot his fiancee Inez
Ericsson was tied up and essayed the
suspect said to her I Am The Night
Stalker a young man that happened to be
outside working on a bike witnessed a
suspect's car and got a partial plate
at first Los Angeles police thought that
the murder of a young woman last March
was an isolated act of violence but
since then they've come to believe it
was connected to a wide-ranging series
of assaults by a killer who's become
known as The Night Stalker a killer who
apparently struck again during the
weekend we have a report from Nadine
Berger
police today continued to search for any
clues in the near fatal shooting of 29
year old
Williams and the rape of his girlfriend
they're apparently the latest victims of
the Night Stalker thought to be
responsible now for 34 brutal attacks 14
of them fatal these serial killings once
confined to the near Los Angeles area
are now spread over 500 miles from San
Francisco to Orange County
just as before the assailant entered a
house in a quiet middle class
neighborhood in the pre-dawn hours on
Sunday through an unlocked window and
attacked the couple while they slept
neighbors are terrified guy just sleep
with my hand on my right by my bed in a
sawed-off shotgun
which I always have I see why is that
because if anybody comes in my house
they're not leaving a killer who attacks
randomly is described as white 25 to 30
years old with a predominant feature of
badly sleeping so 5 000 fires have been
distributed
they just mentioned
and last week San Francisco mayor Dianne
Feinstein announced ballistic dogs have
definitely picked the Ridder of a man
there to the next stalker but release of
that information is outraged a Los
Angeles Sheriff frustrated by the
difficulty of tracking a random murderer
it places this community in Jeopardy
because it impedes our ability our
ability to go forward fully with the uh
investigation a total of thirty five
thousand dollars or rewards has been
offered including today a 16 donation
from this group of concerned school
children
CBS
it is interesting because I feel like he
is his physically when you see him he is
very striking yeah yeah he feels that
can be easy to identify 100 yeah he
looks
very unlike anyone I've ever seen yeah
yeah um he's very totally
so the car info
um is released to the media they end up
getting a call from a gentleman who says
that it's his friend's car which has the
same description in Orange Toyota was
recently stolen in Chinatown yeah the
play on that stolen car matched the
partial plate that the young man
recalled the car had been found
abandoned in a parking lot after the
police surveilled it for some time they
take it in for fingerprints and they're
able to pull a Latin fingerprint from
the rear view mirror at the time
fingerprints weren't weren't automated
so they had to wait until they had a
suspect to match it to yeah
and this just shows like the his crimes
are moving further out of La yeah now in
Orange County
so day 163 investigation this time yeah
so investigators get a call from a woman
who says her father had befriended a guy
named Rick who they think may be the
Night Stalker I wouldn't please
interview the father he said that Rick
talked about killing an elderly Asian
couple in Monterey Park with a 22. which
uh which that info was never made public
uh Rick had given him
uh Rich I'm sorry Rick had given the
weapon to the father and said he had
sold to someone in Tijuana so the cops
end up recovering this gun in Tijuana
and they also recovered a boombox that
was stolen during uh two of the other
murders hold on hold on Rick huh
this dude Rick hmm he told him that Rick
had sold him the gun or what
yeah so Rick no Rick was bragging to
this friend he made that he killed this
couple and then he gave the gun and then
he sold the gun to this friend
he told Rick he sold the Gunner he sold
it to his friend
he's he sold to his friend okay this guy
who called the police right well this
guy's daughter
huh this guy's daughter called the
police and said my dad has befriended
this guy who I think is a Night Stalker
yeah well I mean it's kind of it's kind
of nice just how like opening and you
know open-minded this guy is just let me
be friends with anybody oh yeah no he
said that that this uh I watched the
part where they uh her interview or
whatever I read it she said something
about her father hanging out like on
skid row and like hanging with uh some
bad people so but yeah they found the
gun in Tijuana and they were able to
match it wherever they found the gun
there's also a radio there that they're
able to match with one of the crime
scenes and the only reason they're able
to match that is because the son of the
victim still had the receipt for the
radio because he bought it as a gift for
his parents
um at that time also a police informant
in San Francisco turned in a bracelet
that he thought might be linked to the
night soccer case
um they traced the basically they traced
this bracelet back to this guy
um Armando Rodriguez yeah
um and Armando's girlfriend described a
friend who he had been hanging out with
named Rick who was uh wearing a black AC
DC had a black member's only jacket and
had bad teeth uh so San Francisco go to
see Armando to follow up on this lead
and he's outside
um and they ask him for help in solving
The Night Stalker case uh he tells him
no at first but after he starts fighting
with the cops he ends up giving them the
name Richard Ramirez
so this dude
yeah yeah
he it is interesting the way this is
told because like
we watched a few documentaries on it and
it seems like every time this part comes
up
the cop is like at first he said [__]
you I'm not telling you anything and
then like he goes like the cop is like I
thought about all the victims and it got
me so mad so I [__] clocked him and
he goes and then he goes it wasn't my
hardest and he goes oh that's all you
got [__] and he goes I really
thought about it and I hit him again and
then the guy's like all right it's
Richard Ramirez but like yeah it is
weird every time I've seen that I'm like
well it sounds sort of so wait who this
dude um
somebody with this bracelet said I got
it from this guy
yeah so they had just an informant on
the street and then they said yo where'd
you get the bracelet they followed the
bracelet he's like I'm not telling
anyone okay yeah and then they beat his
ass yeah and they told him well the
person who gave this to you he's a nice
stalker so we need you to give us his
name and he refused yeah he's like nah
damn and I mean props to him dude you
know what I mean like he keeps it tight
no snitching yeah it's morals love that
for him
August 30 day 166
the San Francisco police give LAPD the
name they had eight Richard Ramirez in
the system one of them matched the
fingerprint they had from the orange
Toyota he had a light criminal record
including petty theft and Grand Theft
Auto but nothing violent they
cross-referenced his booking photo with
the informant and the informant
confirmed that that that it's him that
was Rick his friend Rick yeah and later
that day both LA and San Francisco held
press conferences to release a name and
photo of the Night Stalker
oh now he's now he's [__] yeah yeah
this is the next day nope
shortly after identifying him the media
goes public with his name and photo and
they plastered his face like everywhere
all the newspapers and it was just all
over La a librarian at the LA Central
Library recognizes Richard as a recent
patreon of the library he remembers
Richard due to his awful appearance
smell and the fact that he was looking
for books about humans right right sure
all right yeah yeah that's a that's a
red flag I guess
oh yeah I recall a guy came in last week
he was asking if we had any any books on
human torture and uh
yeah not a request you get every day I'm
assuming
so after the medium went public with his
identity the cops assumed Richard would
leave Los Angeles so they had undercover
cops waiting at a Greyhound bus station
because they knew that's how he traveled
in the past at this time Ramirez is
actually out of town visiting his
brother Ramirez returns to LA on that
next day after they revealed his photo
to the city and spots the undercover
cops at the Greyhound station how do you
spot the cops yeah well good well so I
asked Lena the same question
um because he could tell just because
like he himself like being all dirty and
disheveled he can tell when someone
that's how they made the cop
um they gave him like dirty clothing but
their skin was clean their teeth were
clean so he's able to spot that their
undercover cops they're not actual um
homeless people morons
[__] idiots
so after he spots undercover cops he
walks to a nearby liquor store and when
he's inside he realizes his face is on
every newspaper after seeing this he
panics and gets on a nearby bus
this is pretty epic yeah he uh Richard
gets on the bus and then people start to
recognize him and so while he's on the
bus he he gets off and he begins to run
on foot and he starts to run across this
highway
um he runs on the I-5 freeway continues
to run until he tries to carjack a man
he wasn't able to problem so he
continues to run he runs into a lady
named uh Angelina De la Torre and tries
to steal her car and says to her in
Spanish give me the keys or I'll kill
you she recognizes him and shouts it's
the killer which gets manual day
latora's attention this guy's a [__]
Legend he grabs a metal stick from the
yard and hits Richard over the head like
repeatedly he knocks him down and
Richard gets up and starts to run but
Emmanuel just kept hitting him let's go
Dan can you switch off for one second
from the PowerPoint yeah
um people in the studio okay you're good
ready you can put it back
I was just uh afraid because there was
he like he put like a gash in Richard's
head and I was just curious if it was
still in the power plant but yeah
so the whole neighborhood started to
recognize what was going on and started
to chase him down an officer named Andy
Ramirez pulls up to the scene and sees
the crowd has beaten and detained him
one of the members of the crowd was
restraining him with the metal bar he
got his the hole and it was it was so he
got jumped by the whole Barrio dude it's
it's so awesome how it happened because
you know uh racial tensions you know
especially in the 80s uh I mean you guys
know better than me but I'm sure towards
the Latin Community was wasn't great and
now they have this guy who did all these
horrible things but he was uh who is len
but he was captured by this by this
group of Latin of the Latin community
and it was just awesome I mean even the
arresting officer his name was Ramirez
as well Andy Ramirez but it was just
awesome how this community came together
and just beat the [__] out of him and
held him down that is pretty yeah that's
an incredible ending yeah capture
so yeah officer Ramirez is the one that
handcuffed him and put him in the patrol
car
Jesus Christ
after he got caught
I love how humiliating
it was to get beat by everybody it was
he he and it's not in here but when he
gets arrested oh [__] sorry he talks
about how like that guy's lucky I didn't
have a gun on him he felt so tough
because everyone was around he wouldn't
be so tough if I had a gun you got
jumped bro Street
or up
things just a little dizzy and tired
definitely can cost probably he just ran
across the highway
chased by half of L.A
oh
yeah
[Music]
what's up how long ago
what's your name
hello
cute I remember when he was caught
um a bunch of people actually nailed
them the police were after him and they
they stopped him I guess he was trying
to
steal a car or something I don't know
but I remember seeing him on the news
when he was coming to trial and man his
eyes were I mean he just looked Wicked
you saw somebody like that on the street
you'd run I mean this guy looked really
scary I just remember being really
relieved that this man was caught
because man it was scary I didn't want
to go out at night I was only 30 years
old I'd like to still think of that as
being young anyways that's my
recollection and I remember it anyways I
hope that helps ciao
thanks Donna
all right so Johnny this one oh whatever
you want so Gail and Frank uh hear that
he's in custody though they drive to
police station where he's being detained
and it was like a concert like everyone
was there uh they could hardly get
inside
um and they finally get a chance to
interview Ramirez in their interview
room and Frank began to introduce
himself and Richard's like I know who
you are
um he knew a Frank's reputation
reputation for solving the hillside's
Wrangler case and they found out that he
studied these other cases and he was
like a fanboy of the hillside Sprangler
and these other serial killers they even
like when they're trying to get a
psychological read on him they told him
that this is the cell that the Hillside
Strangler was being held in and he got
like all excited about it yeah
though trial and conviction at first at
his first poor appearance Ramirez raised
a hand with the pentagram drawn on it
and yelled hail Satan he was charged
with 13 counts of murder five counts of
attempted murder 11 counts of sa and 14
pounds of burglary during his trial
which began in 1989 Ramirez was faced
with the overwhelming evidence including
fingerprints DNA and eyewitness
testimonies linking him to the crimes
his defense team tried to argue that
Ramirez was heavily influenced by drug
use and a troubled childhood but they
have evidence against him those lawyers
are going to hell was compelling yeah
yeah it's crazy I mean
yeah they're going to hell what's was
the was the whole Satanism thing was
that ever like really explained is that
a part of like his daily practice or is
it just some spooky [__] he likes to say
it was he talked a lot about it a lot
more in prison also
um he says like Satan is everything and
even in the interrogation room when he
first met with Gil and Frank
um Gil got really scared because uh
Ramirez just put his head down like this
and like started humming and like
lifting his hands like that and Gail
thought like something Supernatural was
about to happen like he was summoning
yeah so and he was like well versed in
and he studied it oh my God
let's see I think Gil thought something
magical
he was so rational he was such a good
investigator then all of a sudden magic
so they put him in a lineup and they
brought in this Brave little
six-year-old girl Anastasia
um but she was a victim a surviving
victim of his and she identified him
from the lineup which really helped push
the case she's amazing yeah I think she
said
yeah she has guilt do you want me to
write the number two or write out two
that which he was number two in the
lineup but it gills
yeah on the stage
each man will be assigned a number and
will be referred to only by number
two step to the Red Square in the center
of the line
number two in a loud clear voice repeat
this statement shut up [__]
number two turn to your right and face
the door
if you can
yeah
um but when when she said that it like
broke down Gill is my understanding and
he he ran out and because he has
daughters of his own and he talked with
Frank and they decided to not press the
charges because they didn't want to put
her through any more of this they didn't
want to have her in the courtroom or any
of the kids or any of the kids yeah they
didn't want to put them through they had
him on and off already yeah he was
getting [__] over either way so they
wanted to leave the kids out
and despite all this [__] up [__] this
guy still had an insane amount of
groupies
um during his trial he garnered
attention uh from fangirls they were
they were crazy about him even driving
to the police station and like going
between courts there was girls flashing
the police car
and uh
and and remember where he the most
strange murder what did he do in that um
that amazed me uh I didn't hear about
that until I was after I was random for
a while and he didn't really want me to
read all the articles about him because
he I think he didn't want me to find out
about it but I already broke into
somebody's house and ripped out her eye
and
had sex with her eye socket did you hear
that he raped a 12 year old boy is that
cool
and she's saying she liked it yeah what
the [__] are these people these girls
like would come visit him in jail too
like even like one of the girls like 16
was like crazy around he was a 16
and what's he was 16. yeah
they allowed visitors starting to think
this Richard Ramirez guy has a creep
yeah
she's trying to get a real bad Vibe
about this guy as Tom Tom Segura said
real knucklehead we're really in tune
yeah
um
I think he got marriage proposals yeah
yeah we have that it wasn't one of his
jerseys oh God yeah one of what the
people with their face like that
um
I don't know do you know anything about
that he said was sent someone on the
jury sympathetic of him
I think so yeah I think there was one of
the members empathetic in what way like
romantically yeah like attracted to him
another if I'm not mistaken someone else
on
what's the evidence on that what's the
story there with that juror I'm not
familiar I thought there was just an
overall I guess he eventually got her to
to convict because the the evidence was
overwhelming I think another juror was
killed right before and and like they
scared the [__] out of everyone right
yeah but it wasn't it wasn't related
yeah it wasn't related but
um but yeah that's even today Richard
has uh band pages on YouTube I couldn't
believe it I found this this page
um these are some of the comments he
there's like Richard Ramirez laughing
compilation
yeah and like uh here can I see one
because I saw like oh his laugh is so
cute I gotta hear dude it's like dude I
I these people must not really know what
he did
no they did like like he raped children
that's vibes
but it's been um that's happened with
other serial killers too like Ted Bundy
had a bunch of fangirls even Jeffrey
Dahmer
um all had women like infatuated with
them it's really weird
but I don't think either of those guys
like are worded and murdered children
which to me is like
that's not sex there's nothing sexy
about that that's like you know kind of
a boner that's a boner killer when the
kids enter the equation
these comments are insane his laugh is
so cute though not gonna lie has a cute
smile
I love his laugh I hate to say it but he
was so handsome he's the cutest thing
his little laugh
because oh my God that goofy laugh kills
me yeah I know go go into a room with
just you and him and see how cute his
laugh is Ramirez they should be banned
the show should not even exist
oh I don't know
okay
oh you're talking about yeah we didn't I
did I mean yeah we don't
but uh yeah here's one of the channels
see it's it's it's not clear
uh that it's a fan Channel until you
like
I was like reading the the titles I'm
like okay so here left compilation
that's so [__] nice the way you know
he didn't laugh one that I didn't hear
him or laughing laugh and smile wait
what people are saying his laugh is so
cute I don't hear a single goddamn laugh
it's more from his interviews
from jail oh go back go okay so we
didn't see the whole thing do we
[Music]
says and I hope you get exactly what's
coming for you I don't know how you mean
that I mean it's just the way you know
I'm doing it
all right you're gonna end it now
[__] yeah we need to find out who
these people are
sounds like Patrick from SpongeBob when
he laughs
Simon Says
so cute like little kid
yeah like a little kid seriously
yeah
FBI better be monitoring this chat
comment
there are so many literally every all
the Columbine kids like the both of them
have fan groups people they're just so
insane yeah
I cannot believe it do we know about uh
Richard Ramirez like
come up like his childhood yeah it was
[__] it was yeah it was Mega [__] [__]
[__] he didn't have the best
background so he um suffered a brain
um a brain what this is what sorry not
interrupt you but this is what a lot of
his Defenders will say okay about his
brain injury but yeah go ahead so yeah
he had a head injury and he was like
really young like under five years old
and then another one and when he was
like eight or nine and that one resulted
in like he would get constant seizures
after that
um and then even outside of that like
his father was very abusive his father
was yeah his father was abusive and he
had an uncle that was in the Army and he
would like he came back from Vietnam and
was like telling them stories of how he
would like uh killed some ladies in
Vietnam showed him photos
Polaroids how he would chill and
mutilate their bodies it's and Ramirez
is very young at this time he's like 12
years old when he's being influenced by
all of this yeah
these serial killers always have
straight demonic childhoods yeah so it's
like you know on one hand they're the
product of their environment but
did he have any anyone like close to him
when it happened did anyone like visit
Court
um his he so he has a family like he has
his two parents a brother and sister
that were there for him in court and
they were kind of just in denial about
it
they go he is such a beautiful laugh how
could he do this
his hand with the pentagram and said
hail Satan he said
you thank you Joe he does that
he's got your palm
so um like you mentioned Ethan he did
get married in prison in 1996 he married
Doreen Leroy he claimed to believe that
he's innocent
of course
yeah that's what she believed but he's
innocent yeah she would go on interviews
and say he didn't he didn't do it and
did they ever get to spend alone time
because I'm pretty sure she would not be
here still
she was visited before they got married
she was visiting him like up to four
times every week in prison conjugal what
does that mean did they have sex oh no
she wasn't allowed it was between the
glass okay
well here they are doing it here yeah I
guess for the marriage ceremony oh okay
okay yeah they're special
well look at her what a what up hmm the
grandma and the murderer what a great
um yeah I can understand why she had to
go find a serial killer for her uh her
family I can say it about her yeah she's
vile yeah her family was like really
upset they disowned her after this good
um
me wearing socks and sandals was bad she
should hear about this lady's husband
I'd be honest about something yeah go
ahead
this is kind of goblin mode but she
looks like Ethan Slater in a wig
Ethan Slater's mom let me reorient
myself a little bit I am okay I see it
okay well okay same smile yeah the shape
of everything is happening
I wonder if she can tap dance I think
Goblin Mode's okay
um so yeah he was sentenced he was
convicted of all 43 charges 13 counts of
murder five attempted murders 11 counts
of essay and 14 burglaries uh he was
sentenced to death in California's gas
chamber and decision uh
was met with relief from the victim's
families yeah so also we didn't include
this but we didn't want to put too much
about the victims families you know if
because but they they've talked about
obviously you know the fact that uh
these killings have had on them and for
like future generations and while they
were in court they would be sitting
there like one of the victims
granddaughters was talking about how she
was sitting there waiting to go inside
the court and there's another little boy
there's another young man who was there
who she thought was a victim at first
but it turns out that when he turned his
hand he had a pentagram on his hand he
was just a fanboy of uh
at his trial yeah that's disgusting yeah
and after the sentencing he was walking
out and he told reporters a big deal
death always went with the territory
territory See You in Disneyland the
trial cost 1.8 million which was at the
time uh made it the most expensive
murder in the history of California
until it surpassed by our boy OJ in
1994.
okay the juice
um so yeah here are some of the other uh
crimes that other murders that we didn't
even talk about you can kind of see the
map
of where they were That's not including
San Francisco and the ones that weren't
investigated in relation to this case
um but it was later learned that he
committed other murders prior to even
moving to LA because he's from Texas
um in 1984 he committed his first
potential murder which was a
nine-year-old girl
um who he stabbed and hung her body from
a pipe
um he lived in San uh I'm sorry yeah
this happened in San Francisco
um
initially thought it wasn't linked to
him but in 2009 DNA matches linked him
to that murder
uh also when he moved to California he
murdered a 79 year old woman even prior
to the first case that was investigated
in this investigation yeah so and also
he kind of taunted some of the San
Francisco officers and brought up other
cases that weren't solved implying that
he also
uh killed more people in San Francisco
when they would interrogate him yeah
after he was caught
after the nine-year-old girl was a
nine-year-old sorry uh yeah yeah after
finding out about the nine-year-old girl
uh his wife left him oh yeah just that
yeah
come on I thought it was you know
[__] for the river through Better or
Worse
DNA ruined this marriage why were the
other murders okay girl yeah
heartbreaking man
so Richard or mayor spent more than two
decades on death row while appealing his
sentence however he never got the chance
for a new trial as he died of
complications related to b-cell lymphoma
on June 7 2013. answer
the age of 53
yeah that's actually good that he died
of cancer
slow painful yeah hopefully he got
horrible treatment it would've been nice
if he was a little bit older though yeah
I wish he did just suffered in jail
longer
him in HD is like extra horrible
mm-hmm
so acknowledgments we would like to
express our gratitude to Netflix for
providing valuable information really
contributed to the research and content
in this PowerPoint presentation Lena
actually reached out to which library
was it oh the UCLA Library she had all
this good footage like they sent like an
itemized list and like it was really
good people like an archive of all the
news footage from like dating back even
earlier than the 80s too but the prices
were insane yeah it was like 500 for
like two minutes footage oh to license
it from them yeah we thought they were
just we weren't sure how it works yeah
it's like maybe they were obligated to
share with us I thought it's available
for everyone Public Library yeah no no
you have to license it beautiful
research idea thanks
um this is just to acknowledge uh the
template in which we made the PowerPoint
base it off of We Have Faces included so
let's go did you look closer that was
just the slightest so just keep this
that's all I asked out there it is
um that's it
okay what was that what did it have
their phone number chip what did you
show
it says it says include this and yeah if
you're going to use this to include oh
okay okay
all right fantastic there it is
really really really really good work
very good thank you for listening I'm
gonna thank you for telling me all right
let's um go back to our swap out right
[Music]
hello
[Applause]
um
[Music]
yeah there's a lot
you know
one of the disturbing angles of this of
a lot
it's just the fan girls
the groupies
it's so [__] psycho man
it's just so effed up but there it is
Richard Ramirez was he connected to the
Cecil Hotel I thought he was
we only know that he stayed there a few
times oh he stayed there okay
did they say the stink still lingers to
this day
well
what did we think very good thank you
guys
cheers my dude cheers my dudes
how long we've been going
251 251 yep so I don't have anything
under three hours I don't have anything
else planned
so I just shoot the [__] what do you
want to talk about
you want to order I think I probably
leave before the foo gets here darn it
did they they uh so how's everybody
doing today let me see
[Music]
let's see if I got anything in the dock
how'd you guys like that everybody
watching vibes
yeah I wasn't sure if it'd be too much
for some people so I am curious that
one's pretty yeah that one's pretty bad
yeah
so yeah Lena
I had this idea and she did all the
research for it I kind of just helped
with the PowerPoint but uh we this case
we were kind of just doing his practice
because we were familiar somewhat
because of the documentary so we're like
we'll do this just for format but then I
don't know as we started to work on it
we found out that not a lot of people in
the office were familiar with it and
then I don't know we kind of just got a
vibe off people that they weren't
familiar so we're like whatever we'll
make this uh we'll make this one see
what people think
I think on future ones it'd be fun to do
or like the Swedish guy like I don't
know anything about it sounds
interesting yeah like some like you know
right knew some new ground although it
was fun I mean The Vibes were good
people's liked it
yeah really great job presenting guys
thank you Lena was very very nervous so
yeah oh my God we couldn't tell you did
great so I asked Olivia for some
pointers and you gave me some great
advice so thank you for that oh my god
oh PowerPoint advice I'm gonna get some
from Lena now PowerPoint girls
PowerPoint girls yeah
very good Power Puff Girls Girls let's
talk about it now eat a spicy chip
oh people are asking for health updates
okay I'll give you a health update
so I've been sharing all the health
updates so I'm going to keep sharing
them
so I did the blood test yesterday
they're so fast man they got the results
already this morning
and I wasn't sure but so I didn't test
the Ana it was just like a complete
blood panel right C CBP that's what they
call it
um and I had been sick recently too so I
was a little bit like I don't even know
if it's gonna be accurate but I'll tell
you um
it doesn't have notes from the doctor
yet okay
there's no there's no exclamation so
there's three no exclamation marks no
speckled and no genius good news well
hold on that we didn't run that test
okay that's not good news that's bad so
we just did like the um we just did a
blood test we didn't check the Ana and
the immune response stuff but one of the
reasons that we started looking into
this whole thing was the white blood
cell count
and the platelets so
I'm happy to report that my white blood
cell count lowered actually it's hot the
high side of of a normal range nice
9.57
oh I guess it's slightly above the they
say the normal high is 9.95 but I'm
right there baby
and then the platelets
is high still but actually went down
it's at
493 now and the last one was at like
750 or something so those are thank you
slide whistle
um so that I didn't expect that
that's not the part that like indicates
lupus that would be the
Ana but I don't know because this is the
whole reason I went in there so
um
so that's good news I I guess better
than it going up
so that's the CBC Auto oh wait no
yeah that's the CBC Auto differential
whatever the [__] that is here's the CBC
same thing
and then there was another one
differential automated
and then this one everything was normal
another one I never had a I have normal
test on this one
but it continues to be normal
so that's pretty good news I think
I might not the white blood cell red on
the platelet count
and people say gas like leak related I
don't think so right I mean I don't
think natural gas can do that nah
as far as I understand
and I asked my doctor too about it
um
could it be mold related
I again I don't the mold problem wasn't
like catastrophic you know
I'm seeing no relation
right and I think
I don't know about the mold but yeah I
think it wasn't that severe
but uh who knows I mean [__] but now I
have to go on this weekend I'm going to
do the ultrasound
that'll be a good uh update for us
and then from that I'm just going to see
a rheumatologist but
let's see
you know
Shredder update I mean he's sick he's
still sick he's doing well like
physically he seems fine which is what's
so [__] weird but he's we're actually
having the vet come check on him on
Friday do a blood test see where he's at
was everyone saying foosi what do we
miss that foosi did
how old are you
what did fousey do it vibes
um
here's a here's a clip with Demi's
sister by the way it's kind of
interesting
from the subreddit that means to start
having to act out gross weight loss
scenes on Desperate Housewives maybe
explains why they're a bit extreme when
it comes to anything diet related I do
know that scene it's crazy that's her
yeah that way you could run around
dinner no no so but this means her mom
let her be cast as like little fat girl
in in this scene that uh mom drives
and makes her daughter run after the car
right it's in here let's see
down in the sun there would make you
feel good
oh it is
so okay
um
great
the crew should have a police
illustrator on that's kind of awesome
and described
like famous H3 lore people sketches of
us that's a good answer yeah that's
pretty funny
oh no gamer sub said they discontinued
pina colada
I asked them on their website what a
tragedy yeah
tell them to bring out the whole ocean
well the good news is we're gonna have
our our own flavor coming up here
at the end of the month
uh
what else guys
fousey what fousey said the n-word
yeah he sang he was singing a song it's
pretty uh where's the clip I'll watch it
I feel like he dude he turned it around
quick and that the n-word that meant
that must be the fastest n-word to
apology
time ever you know what I mean yeah
I don't think anyone's gonna be mad at
him about this just because
his reaction
yeah how he handled it uh but his boy
keemstar had his back he was sure to to
share that that's hell yeah that's how
of course he did [__] keemstar the
bigger concern is him getting banned I
feel like
he hasn't yet [__] well he keeps saying
that but he's still up yeah just a
peaceful warning careful twit especially
not when you're doing so good you got so
many viewers that really gonna have
their eyes on you
I love you
here he is why does it look like he's in
prison
this is apartment oh it's a hotel room
it's uh it's so empty it's a friend's
house he was staying in Chicago I
believe it's like the emptiest room I've
ever seen
oh that's so our hat it's a Teddy fresh
hat let's go
I've seen emptier all right so here's
fusi apparently saying the n-word
but I can't even play the song I can't
play this song
well here you get you get what happens
and then you see the feels hard
I mean
pretty iconic reaction
and can you hear him
bring up the ball I never use that
[__] word I've listened to rap songs
every day on this subathon and I always
change it out for brother I had a tweet
that literally said I had a tweet that
literally said I hate when the streets
yeah so I mean
I think he saved it it's not my place
obviously I'm not I'm not a black I'm
not black American not African-American
and so it's not my place to say but I do
I didn't see people really mad at him
because he
yeah that was a quick apology man
and he was devastated he's punching his
bed dude
I couldn't tell if he's doing schtick or
if he was really I don't know
it it seems genuine no it really [__]
him up he was worried about having uh
an episode
because of this oh really because of
this let me hear the audio
all right
that word I swear to [__] God this
isn't content I never use that [__]
everything is a travestylist listen to
rap songs every day on this subathon so
I don't know I listen I
it's not my place to say
but I thought he did a good recovery
I you know what I mean right that's why
he was like people are asking why he was
like retweeting when Keem put it out and
all that he I I don't know but my
understanding is that he was saying that
he wants to get ahead of it and just be
like be upfront about look I messed up I
don't want you to see a headline and
think that I just openly said it this is
what happened and I [__] up
but again not my place to
to comment um
can you send the keemstar tweet his best
friend keemstar who immediately
put this out
on uh Twitter being like fousey said the
n-word could someone else grab that real
quick I'm blocked and I'm not signing to
my my alt
Daddy
uh we have a comment we have uh the
other dude says as a black man I forgive
him
there it is
we have one black person in the chat
That Forgives him
here's keemstar's best friend
uh uh fousey accidentally drops the
n-word it's like why
why did you do that I guess you got
Cloud fart damn 79 000 likes are people
mad or amused
I I saw in keemstars replies a lot of
people are like talk about the Alex clip
oh that's good
yesterday
I was getting my haircut and he randomly
calls me and he goes or he texts me he
goes I need you to call me and cuss me
out
and uh
I wasn't really sure what was going on
so I just I played uh I looked up on
YouTube Arab guy swearing and then I
called him back and just let that play
this is the clip of it right here that I
sang I guess he was trying to [__] with
some guy he had some random guy he just
met at the park and was like Hey can you
can you drive me I guess drive him
somewhere and then started
tell the guy that uh
he was being chased
huh
he told some random dude that he was
being chased and he's in the car with
him
oh really yeah try to be nice hello
hello
[Music]
no okay
there he is he's out there man has he
has he been alive this whole time is he
not taking a break he is not taking a
break he's a Christ man
there it is let's see
we talked about it all really we've done
it all haven't we folks
we've talked about lizzo
she was apparently shoot uh who I
learned strippers some I guess with a
specific Talent can shoot dildos out of
their vagina that's sick dude that's
amazing
um
[Music]
sounds a lot like that really
nice like
I am curious as the story develops
though on the lizzo thing we'll have to
stay up to date with that
and oh the Lovato crime family reached
out to you we didn't get to touch on it
during the do you want to read his
message
um am I allowed to I don't know
um he I mean he basically said huge fan
not his place to like speak for his
family
he doesn't want to get involved but he's
a fan but yes I wonder what his name is
so we have some allies within the crime
family
we love maybe double Asians perhaps
he'll wear a wire at their next family
meeting oh Thanksgiving wire
yo
I might have a claim against Crowder
oh
that's awesome
oh boy
all right anyway this is my new hobby is
[__] with people that steal my voice
for uh or it wasn't mine it was you Dan
but as it was my show I guess
you know
and that all right I got nothing to say
guys
so that means that's tomorrow is
leftovers
super mega I don't know what to say
about that whole thing I genuinely don't
we got a big show big news tomorrow
trumpy boy indicted again again goldfish
of indictments this is the juiciest by
far though this makes the other two seem
small fresh do you feel like though
the other two kind of it just seems like
a joke at this point it is it's
extremely funny that he keeps getting
indicted me like if the if the last two
didn't come this one would have hit
harder I'm not saying don't it died him
because like obviously everyone no one's
Above the Law and stuff but do not come
like people who could potentially be
swayed by this by the third one they're
just gonna be like this is this is a
circus there's probably even another one
coming right yeah yeah probably a few
more a few more this man's gonna be
have a full house of indictments hell
yeah he's the king he does everything
big
do we have a chair update Dan
do you have a chair up right uh no no
update to share as of now I'm still
investigating
quick yeah I I am not talking about the
super mega thing just because it seems
super complicated
and I don't really understand it
so I will refrain from speaking about it
which seems fair right and I'm not I'm
not friends with those guys I don't I'm
not I have literally no Allegiance don't
accuse me of being like friends with
them I don't know what's happening
someone a girl who worked for them got
essayed
wait as long as I hear somebody said
wait what the [__] he didn't tell me
that
what
what he's probably called he's in New
Jersey right
dead
give me a heads up damn maybe he'll be
back for tomorrow let me see
um his Twitter does say he's in New York
maybe he'll be back tomorrow morning
because he didn't tell me [__]
okay
dude this is like the most dysfunctional
show ever the leftovers I feel like he
would have told us maybe we should just
do it sail without him I'm sure he'll be
here I think he'd be here too if he
didn't tell me yeah we talked about how
we're doing the show next week okay yeah
so I don't know why you talk to your mom
yeah how about that he's coming he's
coming back right now okay there you go
oh there you go he's coming
what happened with super Vega like so
one of their employees
or Fred's got essayed by her
I say I don't even know the facts
you know what I mean
today I only want to talk about the
facts
thank you Colleen
[Music]
da da
dude okay
um where am I
all right we're done we got nothing left
to talk about I'd love to stay longer
but we just didn't prepare for it
you know we've been going for three
hours you're acting like this was like
it's not enough
it's enough we usually go three and a
half you know I mean the people deserve
a full episode I gotta be real I'm about
to soil my pants well that's all that's
I expect yeah that's the least
[Laughter]
piss your pants bro I gotta I got I'm
pulling an Ian right now I gotta pee so
bad dude
um got him
all right y'all fun episode thank you to
Lena and AV for the uh True Crime
segment
and uh we will be back tomorrow morning
for leftovers as usual Friday uh for
after Dark
and I hope a fantastic evening to you my
friends
my family
and we shall see you tomorrow morning
thank you
[Music]